what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
[Applause]
start do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and ring that notification Bell
that way you're going to be notified of
my daily videos I am back in London yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
before we start the show the first is
that we have two clips channels just
pearly clips and pearl daily make sure
you go subscribe to both and we also
just started a just what is it Auntie
Joseph animation an animation Channel
yeah just probably animations it's
excellent just pearly animations um so
go subscribe to that as well sign up to
our membership tears on the fourth tier
you get a one-on-one consultation with
me once a month
um that is for YouTube help so if you
guys want any help with your YouTube
channels I would sign up for that
um subscribe to or follow my new
Instagram just pearly things one
subscribe to wife school and thank you
for a million subscribers
[Music]
um okay so today we have a lovely panel
so why don't we go around everyone say
your name your age your relationship
status and a fun fact about you so start
here and then go around hello my name is
Sophie I'm 22 and right now I'm studying
international relations and I'm
um specifying in development and
economic sustainability in Africa and
black communities in the West
wow
hi my name is tisariki I'm 38 and I'm
engaged fun fact
I have a degree in criminology policing
and forensics however I end up a rapper
are you a rapper yeah oh wow join me too
[Laughter]
now
oh god oh by the way that's um if you
guys want to see me wrap that's on our
third membership tier for the behind the
scenes Vlogs
or maybe it's second whatever the ten
dollar one
hi guys it's your girl Esther the
Nigerian Queen I hope you guys have
missed me I feel like you have well I'm
26.
um
I asked him a fun fact about myself I
can put my leg on my head
I don't know if it's fun but I say it
all the time so
um I think that's it right
oh your relationship status
I'm gonna be like Andrew Tate
I'm not gonna say it I can't disclose it
because my enemies are after okay
hey what's up I'm uh Steven uh people
online know me as Destiny I do politics
and video games online 34 years old I am
married
I spent on the internet forever a long
time long time
I'll tell us this shot that he was
married
um um Auntie Jenny
um 55
fun fact
I didn't know anything about Destiny I
slowed down and the first thing I met
him after I met him yesterday and I'm
surprised that I'm the only person that
don't seems to know who he is so I can't
wait to find that fun fact you're a very
very good driver
oh thank you I'll give you that
professional absolutely how did she
drive you she she was she was getting
road rage yesterday oh my God yeah but
she was on it she was on her [__] back
in New York City I was ready to get in
the comments
you know cut me up I probably was like
puzzle was like oh don't flipping the
finger I was opening my cards I was like
come on name come on come on I'm
disabled I will beat you with my
crutches she did they both opened their
doors and he didn't get out he stayed in
his car huh I was like Auntie I don't
know if you want to do that I do my
son's a kickboxer he showed me how to
defend myself and I've got crutches you
know disabled people we you not with the
crushes beat them with them
that was my fun fact
[Laughter]
all right cool all you need to know is
King riches yeah if you don't know me
already I don't know what rock you're
hiding under yeah so go subscribe to my
channel King riches on YouTube we got a
podcast all kinds of content over there
you should already know my face so go to
my channel that's all you need to know
King Richard you want to know more go to
my channel and you find out more about
me there you go let's keep it moving but
I don't even know if I can follow that
like seriously I'm gonna try
um my name is Camilla I'm on Instagram
at Camilla five star I am 40 years old
um and I am dating with intention that
is my current status yes
not just out here I'm dating with
intention uh fun fact about me is that I
am flexible that's all you need to know
um that's why she's got the intention
all right right I'm with you I like that
um okay so today's topic is has feminism
done more harm than good
um so I'd like to hear from everybody
would you consider yourself a feminist
yes or no Okay so
I think that feminism is very important
but I feel like the way it has
manifested in the West in particular is
now causing a net negative and I feel
like that's why conversations right now
are going to be really important to kind
of hold back that sort of Chaos
um so I'd say that I'm a feminist in the
aspect of
women's rights
um
however I'm not a feminist
the women women who go too far with
feminism I think with a lot of women
they've been given an inch and now they
want to take them all so
um that's my perception on it
um I would say I'm a feminist
um and that's because if not for
feminism I wouldn't be here right now
because I'm here because my mum's able
to work as a nurse bring us from Nigeria
and create a life for us so I'm grateful
to feminism for my life basically
um I wouldn't say I'm like in terms of
the new age feminism I do think certain
women go a bit too far like in terms of
promiscuity I I don't feel like they
should use feminism like to justify
promiscuity but I think a lot of women
now they're using feminine feminism as a
way of justifying bad behavior but
feminine as a feminism as a whole I
can't even say it feminism as a whole I
think is very important and it's helped
a lot of women
um come out of abusive situation and
just Empower women generally
yeah I call myself a feminist I think
feminism has done overwhelmingly like
not good uh there might be a couple
crazy people today on like Twitter and
social media but I don't think we should
let that the entire movement I think
it's important to keep moving in a
positive direction forward while calling
out the crazy people that kind of try to
hold things back
I'm an old school famous
women that know their place
got their rights I know their place
I don't want to be a man I don't want to
be equal to a man
and feminism in the old school days was
nothing like the feminists now so if I
was going to say that I'm a feminist I
would say
I'm an old school feminist and that
these young people who now claim they're
feminists
they're not feminists they want to be
men yeah I agree what's what's changed
from now then to now what's changed is
that they that the lady said that well
she said a mile but I'm speaking that as
a dressmaker they gave us an inch and
they wouldn't take a yard
and it's not it's not helping us it's
not helping us and we've gone from being
able to work being able to vote to I'm
the same as a man I'm not the same as a
man I can't do the same as a man I need
not need men I need men
I would say that is make his day I need
my man just as much as he needs me if
not more but that's what's changed is
that nowadays
the feminism the feminists think that
they need that they don't need men
but if they didn't meet men
where would we be
so I'm a feminist that
in the old school days I I like what
I've been given I've been given an inch
I'm happy with an inch I don't want the
yard I can't handle the yard so me I'm
okay working taking care of my man
and being feminine and I think the
feminists have taken
feminism out of the word feminist it's
to do with being an empowered woman not
being
an empowered masculine woman and I think
that most of the feminists nowadays
they're Butch they're masculine even if
they look feminine and they think that
they're feminists
they've got this on the lion I'm the
same as mental equal and you're not you
know what women hold back know your
place hold your corner
that's my view 100
thank you all right cool so the whole
feminism thing I wouldn't call myself a
feminist I would say that I believe in
equal opportunities but if you really
want equal opportunities it has to be
full-time not just when it suits you I
think a lot of a lot of the ideology of
of feminism is is kind of just like
catered to empowering women and like at
the end of the day a lot of a lot of
times in in reality women don't even
want to be on the same equal playing
field as men because they don't want to
take on certain responsibilities that
men take on so do I think uh you know
people should be paid the same money if
they do the same job of course you know
what I'm saying and everybody should
have the same equal rights as human
beings but it has to be in all aspects
of life not just when it suits you so no
I wouldn't say I'm a feminist but I do
believe in equality between races
races or sixes
yeah races and six I've got a lot of
things going on in my mind at the same
time
feminism and racism makes up yeah right
sexiest genders or everything
I think we
2023 version of the dictionary what is
feminism because I think opinions and
Physicians come into what we believe in
feminism to be because as you said it's
different from the old school to the new
school I would say am I a feminist
ah not by choice
I'd say that I have to do what I have to
do and I have to get by and I can't
necessarily uh stay in my lane and I
can't necessarily not take up a
masculine role because there is no man
in my life to take up that masculine
role so sometimes I have to step out of
my femininity and adopt some masculinity
in order to get by so does that mean
that I sabotage my femininity and does
that mean that I'm not a feminist
because I have to do things outside of
what technically is a feminist I ain't
sure so I think I'm I'm on the fence
right now so I'm a bit confused you said
you you step into your masculinity
because you don't have a man in your
life
because if we're gonna go for old school
look after your man and he does the
manly roles and he does the car and he
takes out the bins and he does all the
masculine things at the old school
feminists might say if if person is
because old school there was you know
husband and wife there was not so many
single women like myself right running
households running businesses paying for
cars getting under the Bonnet all of
those things what I'm saying is
sometimes if I were to stick to Old
School feminine ways
I wouldn't get by okay okay I understand
that's what I'm trying to say
um Auntie did you have something to say
I don't understand me she's coming home
so okay so you were saying that old
school you look after your man yeah and
you know your place yeah but in your
place what's the limits of that place
there's no limits it's just that is a
position that you're holding yeah you're
holding that stance I'm a woman that's
my place right so okay so what do you
okay maybe I need to understand then
what's a man's place a man's place is to
um look after me make sure he's got my
best interests at heart and he has to
make the final decision which improves
both of us he is final decision we're
always being my benefit so when he's not
there to look after you who's looking
after you I make sure I've I've got a
man so any decision I might even meet
for me being on the podcast I wouldn't
be here if it wasn't for him
because before I decided to come on the
podcast
I asked his permission people I think
that's really strange I said what is
your permission what do you think about
it this is what I'm gonna do and there's
certain things he didn't like so I told
Pearl you know what I can't do this I
can't do that I can't do whatever and
then we came to a conclusion but the
final decision is always his and I trust
him with it because he'll always have my
best interests at heart and I'm a
trained mechanic and maybe that's
because you've got a good man yeah wait
hold on even if you're a good man that
sounds ridiculous yeah maybe because I
can't I can't do what you just I can't
do what you just said I can't because
why would you need permit like there
might be boundaries within the
relationship so for instance like I
don't want you to do like a pearl like
strip show dance thing with like male
strippers like I can understand that
because that's like boundaries of the
relationship but in terms of like I need
your permission to do a show because I
like if your boyfriend or husband or
whatever if he's not like in this world
you probably know better than he does
like what's better for you I'd imagine
but the thing is both not in this world
we both don't know about social media he
didn't and it's blown up oh you're in
this world now right right yeah but I
still had his permission so there might
be certain things that have developed
since me being on the podcast that he
doesn't agree with so I will cut them
back I mean if you pick a good guy I
mean he's a good guy yeah but imagine if
he didn't have a good guy yeah
and also you never know if you're a good
guy until until you don't believe that
don't you know yourself better than
anyone no not necessarily because I'm
I'm human I've got bad things and I've
got good things I'm just as bad as
anybody else and I will always take
other people's opinions and then when he
says something I don't always take it as
hard as Pearl knows because thanks to
pearls you know sort of that food
pilgrims we've had to like you know stop
like being stubborn but you've given
enough sorry over your decision making
in life sorry because you can answer
someone
um Auntie what you said is the exact
same situation with me I have a fiance
and I would not come up here unless I've
spent spoken to him about it and he's
actually agreed with it so the only
reason why I'm sitting here is because
my fiance doesn't have a problem with me
sitting here but can I ask you something
right when you got out on the street
which a lot of people don't recognize
when you go out and you dress and you
speak who do you represent when you go
out as a woman in a relationship man
your husband right so when you're at
school and you're in uniform you
represent the school yeah when you go
out as a child you represent your
parents if you have a man you represent
your man you're a couple so people are
going to know that feces you on a on a
podcast and you're doing God knows what
you're going to represent him people are
going to know that's so-and-so's woman
so you have to listen to him you don't
don't he doesn't tell me what to do but
I have to take his feelings into account
do you flip that do you flip that into
does he represent you as well when he's
doing stuff well then the U.S do you
have authority over him to give him
permission to do stuff or not yes
certainly he won't do anything that's
everything it works both ways
yeah he has a final decision if he's
going to do something and he says oh I'm
going to do that and I'm like you know
what I don't agree with that because
it's been so long 32 years and counting
because it's been so long he I he will
know that there must be a reason behind
it that I don't agree with him now he
will either listen to me as I would do
him because I don't have to take
everything he says as gospel it's up to
me whether to take it or not
I will listen to him rather than listen
to my friends
listen to their friends what about most
of us that haven't had 32 years and so
why are you saying that I've been with
my man two years and I must what he says
goes this is what my struggle is what
I'm trying to say is you've been able to
build that trust you you've been able to
know that he's got your best interest at
heart yeah you've been able to know that
he has your rights your right intentions
but most of us haven't had 32 years to
practice all that you know I can't adopt
your position can I say something do you
know something right you as a woman
would know within the first six months
whoever that man is for you I can't say
that I would know me personally I
wouldn't know I was a single parent just
like you I was a single parent and we
split out but when I met him back he was
a single parent
so I know that anything he says if it
jars in my heart I have to think they
must be know what that don't feel right
let me discuss it but if I think to
myself I am not going to be a detriment
then I'll go with it because it's not
harming me
so every if I think in my head as a
woman that what he's saying doesn't
benefit me or harms me I will discuss it
and then because it's not the fact that
oh what he says goes I will discuss it
with him and I want to hear where he's
coming from because all right then for
instance you've got a man and you both
of you have a favorite artists
and the favorite artist gives you two
free tickets to go
and then your man looks at ticket and
says you know what you're not going what
would you do
like this conversations couldn't happen
with my man anyway honestly I think that
I think the modern relationship is way
too uh it wasn't no let me say the
modern relationship I'm looking for is
way too equal in terms of opinion and
position there's there's a conversation
it's about what's making me happy and if
it's taking my best friend to that
concert he wants to see me smile and he
wants to see me happy that's what's
going to happen in that concert but you
didn't answer the question so the
question was I ask you what would you do
like when he asks you to do something
that you don't want to do
but if it's in my best interest I cannot
put myself the only man or the only
being is God that can tell me by speech
by Grace
God says obey your man the man the man
he's my man he didn't put a ring on it
you should be with him until you put the
ring on it right but what I'm trying to
say is if I'm a feminist what does it
mean for me as a single woman that's
what I'm trying to understand from this
conversation okay so can I try to add a
little bit of context on it because it's
like a okay so basically what what
they're saying is okay so yes working
taking out the rubbish doing all of
these things are seen as as masculinity
right however I don't think we're
speaking in that regard because
obviously these are things that have to
be done you have to take out the rubbish
you have to work you have to do these
things but I think we especially as a
single person however we're basically
but you're still a feminine that doesn't
make you masculine what makes you
masculine is when when you're like so
let's put everything in context now so I
said I made the same statement as Auntie
right
so I'm going to put things into context
if I wanted to go shopping in Tesco's
for example I don't need his permission
right because I'm going Tesco's and I'm
doing food shopping if somebody invites
me to a club
or some kind of event
then I need to sit down and speak to him
and explain to him where I'm going what
type of event is what kind of people are
there all right let's let's say for
example I'll put an outfit on and I put
on a short dress and my breasts are
revealing okay now if he says to me you
look nice babe
go out and have a good time
as soon as he's finished that sentence
me and him are done because me I can't
be the guy like that to me that's a simp
okay so if my my man or my husband says
to me
you need to go back and you need to
change because what you're wearing
is inappropriate now look a lot of
people will be like no why why I compare
what I want if I want to work but you're
not you're not thinking because if you
if you're going out with your husband
right and you go to a club or a place
and you're wearing a short skirt and
your breasts are out you'll there's a
huge possibility that you're going to
put your husband in a situation no but
he's next to me
let me land let me land okay so for
example my fiance right if me and him
went out to a place and he wouldn't let
me wear that anyway in the first place
but let's say he did and we went out to
a place right and a guy comes and and
Taps my bum
it's less likely right and if he does do
that if I had a bbo you will attack my
ass not necessarily but look look we we
have to go about intentions if I come to
a place and aren't properly covered up
jeans and a guy does that he's getting
smoked right there's no if so but about
it because this girl is respecting
herself she's dressed up nicely and
you've come out of your way yeah and
you've you've slapped her ass now my
fiance if he was with me right and
somebody did that
there's a huge possibility he's going to
jail for life but then you're wearing
tight jeans why not wear this on long
skirt in it if we're going if you're
going to do more you're going to do what
you can wear along
you can you can that's what you should
do then because you're calling for it
also with the little tightness getting
away from the clothes get hold on
getting away from close you guys this is
what I'm so confused about it Auntie you
kind of did it and then walked to a more
agreeable area do you guys talk about
things that are basic relationship Norms
but you like frame them in the most
toxic way possible I don't understand so
you talk about like if I'm gonna wear
something and go out to a club my boy my
my boyfriend my husband whatever is
going to approve of it which it to some
extent like can make sense in a
relationship context but if you flip
that around if your boyfriend or husband
says I'm gonna go out to party you know
and there's like you know 10 girls there
and like two guys I imagine you have to
okay that right you'd have to tell him
whether or not you give him permission
to do that no yes okay so you guys frame
these things like my my husband is the
ultimate Authority and blah blah but
that's not true for all you guys it's a
back and forth like you're gonna be
okaying what he does he's gonna be okay
what you do that has nothing to do with
masculinity or femininity or anything
like that that's just like two adults
having a relationship figuring out what
the boundaries are thank you yeah so so
what do you mean by your place when you
say auntie because what does he saying
this it is an equal exchange of
um looking up for each other no I think
with me I'm different because if I'm
gonna wear a short skirt and something
sexy I'm always going to work with my
with my man mostly I wear it at home
but if I want to go out and I'll say to
him what do you think about this and do
you know what
what um Destiny said
what we've been saying it's just normal
no more respect for each other
and I respect him and his decisions and
his opinions and he will respect mine so
it's not like I'm blindly following
where he wants to go because Effie
wanted to go somewhere or talk to
certain people other said in the past
you know what I don't like your friends
and as a man I would say you know I'm
not going to say don't go out of him
I'll say in this watch out for this this
is what I spotted this this this and
this and I'll let him go ahead and
eventually he will not you know what you
were right so it's just about respect
but I find that these modern people now
they don't have the basic respect for
each other in the relationship so what
happens in like lesbian relationships
then is I don't know well again
everything the man says everything that
was said is fine for relationships
there's I just there's not like a
masculine feminine like when you start
talking about you're going to talk to
your partner you're going to make sure
that they understand where you're coming
from hopefully you love each other and
you know each other hopefully you both
have each other's best interests at
heart and then you advise it that's at
the end of the day someone wears the
pants like someone's leading and
someone's following it's it's like no no
no sometimes wait and sometimes it's
reverse but at some at some point like
you have to trust someone's leadership
that it's going to depend on the domain
that you guys are experts in right so
you said you were a mechanic right so
I'm guessing that traditionally men are
gonna have to say over the car because
man tend to know but I'm guessing you
probably know more than your husband
does right and if he comes back with a
50 pound bill for blinker fluid you're
probably gonna maybe you're probably
gonna make fun of him right but you know
something right I just put on those and
as you most probably know yes I'm a
mechanic
but he's more stable-minded than me and
as you know from the [__] car that I
picked you up in
right because I must have been having a
blind non-mechanic feminine moment where
I just went in and asked for the
cheapest car with four doors and you saw
it the car's a piece of [__] it's for
somebody single it's not for someone
that's got three grandchildren because
free grandchildren he fills the car but
whereas he hasn't seen the car yet
because I didn't discuss it with him and
he's going to look at me and say why did
you get that car yes I could take it
back but I've decided to punish myself
for being such a stupid woman and
choosing such a stupid car when I was
feeling in my most feminine moments so
yeah I can do that but whereas even
though I'm a trained mechanic
enema nails and there's certain things
that he will do in the no I won't say
that most of the things he will do I
always say your brake light needs to do
it but he expects me to do the brake
light because I'm trying to do just the
brake light I'm just saying that in
every relationship like both sides are
going to know more things than the other
side but like so there are going to be
some things where the husband is going
to have like the grand Authority but not
because he's the man uh but just because
that's the stuff that he knows those
women have like the authority because
she knows about them but the last
decision you see with me we were just
Customs discuss stuff
and I will say this and he will say that
and then
I might be right and he'll say you know
what go with you or he might be right
and I'll say go with you but if we come
to a stalemate me I would say you know
what we're gonna go with you because the
decision is all yours because that's the
[__] it's the fan me as a [__] woman I
will say you know what you made that
decision
so the final decision is always his
whoever he agrees with me or whoever he
you agree or whether I agree with him I
prefer the final decision to be his
because
I just think personally the ideal
situation is when you're with a guy that
you can trust his decision making and I
think the girls and the girls that I see
where they wear the pants in the
relationship they're miserable oh my God
it just depends on the thing like any
there are plenty of women where guys
wear the pants and they're miserable too
there are lots of people in natural
miserable relationships it doesn't
happen both ways sure at times I've just
seen I think that when women wear the
pants they're miserable yes
can I just say why does someone have to
wear the pants
why can't we make decisions together
like he said if you're more if you have
more expertise in that field then say
okay like if I I'm trying to make a
decision with my man now I know about
properties right say he doesn't know
anything about properties I'm gonna be
like oh babe because I've bought a
property this is what I'm gonna tell you
and because he's probably like men know
more about cars I don't know about cars
I will never tell my man anything about
cars because I I assume because men seem
to know more about cars and if he has a
nice car he he's been driving for a long
time I'm gonna think you know what
that's his field why does it have to be
someone wear the pants do you know
something right that's what women feel
to understand when they hear about a
submissive woman do I look like a woman
that just does what her man says no I'm
gonna take for instance you my man is a
saver I like to invest in property he
has got more money in the bank than me I
have got more properties than him
and even when it comes to getting
properties he was a saver he was like no
I need to save money whatever and I was
like this is what I think you know he
said go with it you know what I was
right
it doesn't make a difference
because he made the final decision
because a selfish man
a man that just wants to feel all full
of himself will just go with what he
wants and we're not talking the lady in
the red coat I'm sorry we're not talking
about that we're talking about where
you've got a man that leads and a proper
man when you've got a man that you can
trust he will take into account what you
said he could be taking account what he
says and he would weigh up the pros and
cons and he will come out with the best
decision for you whoever it means you
side with him or whatever it means
inside of you and if he's not sure
he will either say you know what if he's
a stubborn big-headed bullish man he was
like you know what my name so I'm gonna
go no when I was talking about Brandon
property my man didn't agree with me and
I explained you know what this this this
this but it seemed like an impossibility
to him in his mind as a natural saver
but he was like you know what go for it
now we've got the properties he's got
the money I haven't got no money if I
need money I'll go to him but on paper
I've got more money but in reality he's
got more cash so you just don't go with
a man just because because a lot of
women think that oh I might know more
about this but he's the mass he has to
make the fine decision that's lack of
respect if a man respects you he will
take into account your decisions your
research your qualifications before he
makes the final decision and if a man is
going to go with all your knowledge all
your experience all your decision making
and what you've been doing for a
lifetime and go against it but don't you
think about you don't you think you're
talking about skills in a man that is a
man that has lived a man that's matured
a man that has had relationships learned
about himself and others we're talking
about men in their 20s and 30s I have
yet to become exactly and I think so we
cannot we cannot have the same attitude
at all you're talking generationally
completely different I think the value
basis the way that they are raised are
different you are your expectations for
our 2023 men that have been raised with
sometimes very little Foundation You're
Expecting so much for them to have all
of these qualities that your man of X
years and X age and big big age are
having guys I think the point is to pick
a good man that you can change but I'm
talking about we're here now okay we're
here trying to find this good man in the
mecca we're like oh no the nonsense
hold on hold on hold on I've been
listening to like I haven't even said
nothing for ages yeah like it comes down
to who you pick yeah 100 it comes down
to you pick so you can say all of this
oh yeah oh we're trying to find these
Good Men At what age are you trying to
find these good and where where are you
trying to find can I can say thank you
riches yeah right
you're saying about picking the problem
I find nowadays is that the woman is
picking don't let the women pick the Men
supposed to pick no the problem
it's what um Camilla yeah yeah the
problem is at 25 there are no men like
this okay if you're a 22 year old woman
you're not gonna find a 25 year old guy
that's ready to take charge and Lead
everything no that is true that is true
absolutely true that's absolutely true
I'm so sorry I know there are a lot of
children but you're not gonna find a 25
year old guy that has all of it when the
average kid gets out of school today at
like 22 23 years in England you're
thinking well how when in England you
finish college
no you don't university university
I'm sorry we call it different things in
America yeah if in University if you
finish that at 20 to 23 there's no way
full degrees
at 24 25 as a man you are not gonna have
all the faculty that you were when you
reach 30 35 you don't have that lived
experience yet to know what it's like to
lead a household to live a life to exist
in like the world and and to navigate
is so funny that you guys are the first
ones to say that we have two high
expectations and then come and tell us
that we're not picking the right men
that we're just picking responsibility
you can date an older guy if you if you
think that you need a 35 year old guy
I'm all right come on
did you say
I want a young man just like myself so
we can relate together again like I
don't want anything
you guys keep talking about how you need
a man to lead yeah I already know myself
I'm an adult you know I've spent a lot
of time with myself I am in I'm in tune
with myself what I want is partnership
yes Malone I want a man that we can
actually share its experiences together
elitas yeah I think the problem is when
I listen to Pearl and rich as an artist
a little bit mainly you two guys it
feels like you guys are saying that
women need to look for fathers
can I just say something when I met my
man we were both in our 20s thank you
and the thing is it's in the 80s but if
you had the same standards now which I
have met some really good young men that
had the same standards as my men have
but you know what the women don't want
them because they're average men
everybody's videos the women
Auntie can I add something
when I met my man I was average he was
average he was sexy as hell and all the
young girls wanted him do you know what
I mean but we were both average people
and he was he was always sensible from
planning to settle why can't I want
amazing
this is the thing this is the thing why
do I not listen you can want what you
want why can't you get it right is
amazing he's always been amazing he was
amazing
[Laughter]
it's like everybody's saying I need to
have it as average as average why I
ain't average I am not average I'm gonna
let you know right what makes you not
average because if I look at my age
mates my successes my achievements my
personality my drive my motivation is on
it for once are you a single parent
because sometimes as a single parent
because you've been in the relationship
you've been there before you've got
different expectations oh I'm saying I
didn't start as a single parent I met my
husband and I had a child nobody met
nobody meets as a single
parenting my man was a single parent I
was just going against the women my man
was a single parent too
what is
yeah
there's how many people in here wait
eight most of us are average most people
are average can I say something and when
you talk about drive that's the top
things that men look for men
okay so when you when you speak about
average right because remember
everything we speak about needs to be
within context okay so when you spoke
you said compared to my peers right yeah
so age of me so so maybe compared to
your peers you may not be average that
was my evidence however however if we go
to another context right and then we
compare you to people like
Rihanna Beyonce who are one millionaires
hang on right because you're not capable
one second you can because I'll tell you
why let me explain why right when you
meet a guy right you can be very pretty
you could be very attractive you could
be like all of these things right but um
he'll still look at you as average
because oh if if he could if look
there's always it depends what you
compare the average with okay so like
you said with your peers you can apply
that to that but if you apply average on
a larger scale okay where people are
millionaires people are mad famous
millions of followers they all look at
you as average compared to that person
do you wanna stop trying to say
percentages though no but we have to
look overall because you've got to
remember people are being brainwashed
out here they're still they're looking
at Rihanna they're looking at Beyonce
they're looking at the problem all of
these people yes the whole thing if you
don't mind can I just finish what I was
saying so that's the first thing I was
going to say is it's in context right
who you're comparing yourself to because
nowadays is guys are looking for girls
of the majority of guys look I'm I'm a
woman right but all my life I've I'm
Road I'm Hood all my friends are savages
they're all Road man I don't I don't
chill with girls I've got one female
that's my friend all my friends are
males so I hear them when they speak
this younger generation a lot of them
are actually looking for girls with
money that's what they want girls with
money girls with cars girls with like
that's that's how they're they're
thinking now their thinking is
completely different so a normal basic
nine to five working person or or or
working across or whatever is average to
them it's average because they're seeing
these things every day so that's the
first point I wanted to make right the
second point I wanted to make is people
are like oh you know the man should be
in control the man's um uh you have to
listen to the man and the man's got the
power but really and truly right if
you're married right or you're in a
serious relationship with a man you're
the one that's in control you're the one
that's in power and I'll tell you why
because when your husband respects you
right he'll do anything for you you ring
them and say to him look I need milk
he's dropping everything and he's coming
he's bringing milk if you leaving him
and say Tim I need this or something's
happened or he's coming he's coming
running straight for you so really
you're actually in control as long as
there's respect there right and there's
the love there and you're playing your
role when he's playing his his role they
say that a woman is the neck to a man's
head so you can turn his head whichever
way you want to turn his head you just
gotta know how to
what were you gonna say something I
really hate how being a single mother
diminishes your value as a human being
how how you can go from a tense on the
other ones like oh now you're a five
because you're singing but that says
nothing about who you are as a person
this is nothing about your Mastery about
your talent about the discipline that
takes together
listen at the end of the day at the end
of the day yeah you have to just respect
what the market wants what at the end of
the day you know how much money let me
just finish my because I'll let you talk
do your thing I will do my thing yeah at
the end of the day if you don't care
what the market wants and you talk and
you tell yourself oh I'm not average I'm
not average bro like you're just gonna
continue losing rough you should maybe
understand the market guess what
Coca-Cola understands its Market that's
why Coca-Cola is successful bro
so you can be deluded and think armor 10
and this because I'm I'm got money and I
went to this school and blah blah blah
like I bro I do these podcasts the same
thing and these women come and say the
same thing because I went to this school
and I've got money but the market does
not care about that yeah and I'm sorry
and I'm sorry to say it I'm sorry to say
like you're saying Oh but you know uh
single mother diminishing who you are as
a person no you could be a great person
and be a single mom you can be an
excellent person but at the end of the
day the market for the most part is not
going to want to cover it depends
it says something about your decision
making if you become a single mother
are you all right do you know why I
became I have to disagree yeah
to make a choice to be a single mother
you don't pick the right guys oh at
something about your decision making
maybe you don't pick the right guy so
abusive women that choose lovely amazing
men that just decide to be physically
abusive because I chose that yeah is
that what you're saying say that again
so I chose to be a single divorcee
because of a individual's choice to be
violent is that what you're saying it's
your choice to get in a relationship
with him oh because
as a man it says life life turns out
better if you take accountability for
your choices sometimes okay on the man I
disagreement
an abusive man he's wrong I agree with
you
where do we take accountability
so maybe maybe sorry Paul can I just I
have to say I disagree with you yeah I'd
definitely disagree with you then I'll
tell you why look I'm 38 I'm not a young
girl I've been married and I've been
divorced I've got experience I've had a
kid you know I've been there I've done
that so if somebody gets married at a
young age right they're young
right so they're not that clued right
look let me start from the look we
always talk about a problem but we never
ever get to the court of why that
problem occurs everybody's here so
everyone so in a way as a young girl I'm
sure you'll all agree with me okay as a
young girl we are brainwashed we are
sold a fairy tale right we are all
thinking oh we're gonna wear this white
dress and we're going to get married
we're going to be in love and no we
shouldn't have been taught that we
should have been taught the realness
marriage is very hard it's a struggle
you gotta make sure you know who your
married look and also people change over
time somebody who can marry them and
when you married him they were okay and
over time gradually they got mental
breakdown they became a psychopath they
became uh anti-social but again we all
grew up in the same society and people
have different outcomes based on their
choices so if you make a choice can I
finish what I'm saying I think I think
what you're saying everything that we
say has to be within context you know
some people might get married and their
husband dies and they become a single
mother you know we're not talking about
exceptions we're talking about the rule
or the majority of single mothers widows
no but does it go the other way do know
does Men's rally diminish when they
become no it doesn't matter no because
they can just get up and they can go and
run away absolutely personally for me
personally I don't I'm not into the guys
with kids that's not my thing but in
general no I mean most guys I know that
have kids say it helps them in dating
girls like it
yeah no a guy can just get up and start
all over again
ability when it comes to men but as soon
as it's not about accountability it's
about outcomes like what outcomes do you
get and and the outcomes that single
mothers have a harder time in dating a
single women
and the outcome for men is often times
when men not always but oftentimes when
men have kids their outcomes are better
they get more girls because women like
to see women like to see a guy that can
take care of a kid it signals to us that
like you know again it's not my thing
personally I'm gonna add on to that
because I I am well I'm not I'm single
mom but I'm engaged I'm getting married
however before I got engaged and I was
it was me and my child
um it is so so the the guy he can just
literally leave and go and start a whole
new life we remarry have a kid you
however he's not going to take that kid
with him he that woman doesn't have to
ask for worry about that child you're
the one who's gonna keep that child with
you 24 7. so if you try to decide to
date right it's not as simple you can't
just go out and date you've got to think
about your child especially if it's a
little girl or a boy you've got to know
who you're bringing to your house you've
got to know who you're bringing around
your child and then let's say for
example you're like even when you're
married it's the child's own father he
starts to get jealous of that child
he'll start telling you oh I'm not
getting any time anymore so how do you
think a guy who's not even the father of
that child is going to fill would you
want would you want your brother to date
a single mother over a single woman
okay hold on all else equal everybody
wants a person without a child versus a
person with a child that's going to be
true all our sequel the reason why men
tend to get away with it more than women
because women are often the ones taking
care of the kid now you might think in
your mind well I know some single dads
are really successful but single dads
that fight for custody is already a
minority of a minority so you're already
probably selecting for pretty successful
guys so I think there are single dad say
that again single dads that are fighting
for custody of kids who can take care of
their kids you're already selecting for
a pretty rare guy yeah right because
they can't they don't typically win no
because they don't typically fight for
it they usually just cut it around but
the reason is like I've talked to
different attorneys about this and the
reason most attorneys will tell guys not
to fight for custody because it's
because it's so expensive
no no they tell them not to fight
because oftentimes they won't win
because when when a court is trying to
figure out who's going to get custody of
the kids it's very it's very expensive
it's like do you want to waste your life
savings when you're most likely are not
going to win no no no none of this is
true you can go you can look up all the
numbers honestly if you want the reason
why men typically don't fight is because
one they don't because if they fight and
they're in a bad place to win because
they haven't been taking care of the kid
they're not going to have a good account
from the church when the judge is
looking when the judge let me finish let
me finishes okay when the judge is
looking at who gets custody it's not
about who puts up the better defense in
court who's got the more expensive lower
it's who spent most time with the child
so if the mom has spent 95 of the time
with the kid doesn't matter how much you
pay too low you're not gonna win she's a
housewife when men do fight for custody
they win 60 of the time but but the
problem the problem is like women can
make it so the dad doesn't even see the
kid and then go to court and then say
whose fault is that wait hold on wait
wait no no no stop stop stop stop stop
hold on you just went on a whole spiel
about take accountability for your
decisions blah blah blah and now you're
saying what is the mom playing hide and
go seek what exactly take accountability
what do you mean when you say the wife
has made it so the husband can't take
care of the kids well they're they're
you've never heard of cases where women
don't let the dad see the kid hold on
hold on you wait wait earlier you said
we were going to talk about exceptions
you want to talk about the rules so
don't give me the hide and go seek can
it's it's more common than you think
that's you're still you're being sneaky
there when you say that it's more common
than you think how long did you think a
mom is hiding the kid from the husband
give me a percentage give me a
percentage what percentage um that's a
good question
um
I don't know because in the UK if that
be the case and I work in the industry
it's 275 to get c101 application to go
to the court for contact for your child
it isn't what it is in America it's very
easy I can go out and do a bottle for
275. so I don't want to hear that excuse
because I can go to court and police can
turn up at my door right but what if I
go against that order that's what I'm
trying to say it's always expensive what
is the what is the most expensive bad
it's child custody the most expensive
thing is the most expensive the most the
most expensive thing is
[Music]
right and I just want to say
a few things
I was picked
I was in a relationship it was abusive
and nobody can't tell me that with
hindsight you can't see that there's
loads of red flags
so when he asked me to marry him and I
said no if he was a last man on earth I
won't marry you
I saved myself from getting married and
getting stuck in a relationship so yes I
was a single parent whose dad
the challenge that helps me to marry him
and I thought about it and I thought not
on your life and actually said if you
were the last man in earth I'll marry
you
that's the last thing I remembered I was
that cold on the floor
you know why because I couldn't imagine
myself my mom and dad were married and I
thought to myself this guy I got into it
this guy picked me I never picked him
this guy picked me I fell in love
got into a relationship it was abusive
and
I thought to myself the last thing I
need is to get married and tied to this
man forever so if I knew that there were
red flags before when he I could have
turned around and said oh yeah I'm gonna
see you know I mean I want to get
married he proposed to me had the ring
one knee everything I could have said
yeah
then I would have been stuck in an
abusive relationship as a married woman
and then I would have got divorced and
still been a single woman
who'd been married before and an abusive
relationship but I decided no so too
many women out there they think you know
what that will go by they see a red flag
oh that's nothing they see this that was
nothing and then they go along with that
oh yeah let's get married now I could
have gone along with it everybody was
like yeah on the outside you threw
together it's working he drops you
shopping he picks you up he takes you
here he takes you there
but I knew in my heart that he was
abusive nobody couldn't see it and I
decided that rather than get caught up
in the great big wedding scene knock it
on its head so when women are talking
about they're not average as a single
parent I had to be different I had to
stop going out there and thinking to
yourself you know what I need a man I
didn't need a man I know I needed to do
I made the choice I needed to look after
my child I needed to make sure I didn't
have any more children I need to make
sure that I become a positive role model
for him and make sure that he had male
mentors out there so much so that
eventually when I got back to the first
man that I was in love with by the time
we got back together again he was a
single parent
he was willing to take me as a single
parent
and
I took him as a single parent so as far
as I'm concerned don't go if you're a
single parent look for other single
parents
if you can't find no one that you trust
that you can hang over to
single parents unite single men who are
parents go have a single women or
parents because the women who are out
there now nobody wants to be average
everybody wants to be above average but
you know what I'm average this is who I
am I've met somebody average we got on
great and it works I don't want to find
someone with a fancy car when I met him
he never was even driving eventually got
a fancy car and I got it to drive he
gave it to me but you don't hang your
hat too high women out there and the
average makeup don't make you more than
average intelligence don't make you more
than average education don't make you
more than average the clothes that you
wear don't make you more than average
the podcast you go on to do not make you
more than average it makes you popular
Outdoors I'm talking let me finish let
me finish let me experience on it
I can't expand if I don't finish talking
again because I'm in English I'm
Caribbean I'm not African so shut up and
let me finish when I finish talking I've
been sitting here
okay they will be on here talking
[__] speak for yourself say that you
are the best foreign
you as in you and then look at me as a
meme you're saying single moms are
average right and then you're a single
mom and you're a lot older than me and
you're saying look at you and look at me
seriously auntie
are we gonna be ready right now Africans
are the best
right Africans are the best right
you're gonna put yourself up against me
now I was asking Richie hang on I was
actually reaching riches
King Richard the Africa wait wait okay
that's a violation don't disrespect
African people no one has never this
year
he is here saying that African people
are the best right I'm not dispute in
this point of view I'm going back what's
on the stage and I'm saying look at you
right with your knowledge and your
african-ness and look at me and you're
gonna tell me that Africans are the best
I'm not saying that what he's saying is
wrong I'm saying that talk about what
we've got here okay talk about the scent
look at the brain work talk about the
educational and the professional
speaking okay okay
um all right I'm gonna take a second to
read super Dance I'm sorry
um okay guys like the video subscribe to
the channel
um
and especially like that is the most
important metric that YouTube uses to
push out this content so um saying steer
um disapporia Wars UK
um NSK Destiny misquoted the lead
attorney Pearl is right I watched that
entire stream plus others for the lead
attorney where he breaks it down go
watch the lead attorney for specifics
Saint stear have them shed their ego
Auntie um Steve why are you listening to
the chick with the blue hair about
masculinity it's all jereme's fault
sipping on sweet delicious single mother
tears I'm JB quinnon the fragile rock is
dispensing misinformation see Dumbledore
um destiny you are clueless as a top one
percent Man Who as a top one percent man
who also has a Juris doctor and has
spent well over a hundred fifty thousand
dollars in court fees over my kids you
have no idea how family law Works um
pray that you never find out Caleb it's
obvious Pearl goes whenever Destiny is
getting a banger clip to distract people
Alexandria Rubio wrong I lost my son
Destiny is wrong KCF Sac single mothers
always blame men never self-respect Nico
can y'all please stop talking and bring
on Ice Spice zestany in the house and no
ice spice y'all are a Munch where is she
QB quinnin the energy is only attractive
for a corporation HR supervision
anything that's paradoxical to the role
of mammy C Dumbledore tell me you're a
loser without telling me you're a loser
single mothers hold my beer house phone
it's good to see Destiny finally
embracing British culture he looks so
happy sat on that he sat on the couch I
bet he's rethinking all the bad things
he said about us now you got beef with
British people yeah you're not even
British [__] off no I'm asking the
question I didn't know I jumped around
today and as soon as I heard someone say
the word Tuesday I wanted to fly the
back fly the [__] back home okay Jesus
Christ look I'm trying to get out of
this country
I love my British brothers and sisters
JB quinnin um nobody wants a workaholic
ass loss check that's the equivalent to
y'all wanting a sassy man see Dumbledore
an angry middle-aged single mother
divorcee is above average is there and
in what way Jay Queen and being
overweight as a woman makes you average
in the dating Market no matter how you
feel um Chipotle can the granny let the
other guests talk the granny hasn't had
one good point so far Marcus B the
distinction between men and women when
going out is men approach women so a man
so a man going out won't be approached
the same way a woman will be Saint Serge
look at KR just waiting to cook um
Chipotle okay and big name in the
building Destiny is vosh friend orfo
um house phone does this channel have
members and mods uh yes we do sign up
Corin Auntie stopped taking oh this was
from earlier okay okay so next question
okay
I can I didn't get to say nothing oh
okay oh I'm sorry go ahead and then
often can I just add something on really
quickly okay okay go ahead Michael uh so
is this mic even working I don't know it
does we can hear you all right so
basically like the reason why I said
Africans are the best because
like at the end of the day you're not
little uh back and forth you said
something along the lines up oh yeah uh
uh you're African don't tell me nothing
I'm Caribbean and I'm gonna finish what
I'm saying and the way he said it it
came across as like it came across
offensive in it I didn't say that you
said something along the lines not word
for word but something along them lines
and that's why I said Africa is the best
I didn't say in a in a way as um putting
down Caribbeans but I said it is like a
stop so that like like we would actually
start to think about what we're saying
and then it just went all mad from there
but at the end of the day like I just
feel like that like people just say a
lot of stuff and just need to think
about what they're saying when they
rewind it they will say I didn't set up
again I didn't say anything about
Africans no that's not why I said no
you're not listening I said I did that
you said you are African no I never said
that you bro did you hear what I just
said go ahead
because you keep on calling me bro I'm a
woman I've not got balls you might think
I am but I ain't so I'm asking you I
didn't understand what you said in the
first place for no reason to me again
you're too hyped to be honest I think
honestly and I won't call you bro ever
again I think honestly that you're too
hyped for no reason bro to be honest
like you're just hyped for no reason and
your proof is well everyone everyone can
rewind and watch it and see users I
think he said something it sounded like
you were disrespecting him for being
African and he's like Africans are the
best not to [__] on you for being
Caribbean but because he wanted to like
stop that train of thought I think
that's what happened there
yeah
my best friends are African friends
[Music]
okay we like we like Africans and
Caribbean everyone's cool okay and white
people yeah white people too you know
everyone right here
everyone needs to just be careful how
you speak because people will take
offense like if you say things in a
certain type of way or anything like
that it will people will take offense
especially Caribbean people maybe people
need to listen
to be careful what they say
let's just agree to disagree
[Music]
okay okay I'll give you I'm gonna give
her a chance to respond just because
you've talked a lot do you want to say
thank you yeah
yeah which is just can you speak on the
mic yeah I think our microphone might be
off is she muted okay
I think Auntie you seem to have um a
pattern in which you say things and not
realize what you've said because that's
what you did to me last time I don't
think you even realized because I think
you said something about faith whatever
I'm not gonna bring it back but the
point is because it's happened before I
think you don't realize that it's what
you're doing so I'm not even calling you
out right now I'm just saying maybe just
because
excuse me do me a favor with this name
put your head back a bit I want to see
her cool me out cool me out on what I
said I said you're faithful this week
right right let's go there you want to
go back in the pasta embarrass yourself
again
cool me out get over here
you even offended him and I'm just
saying maybe sometimes just listen to
people when they're saying they're
offended by what you say maybe just stop
and think tell me exactly what I said
that offended him
definitely what I say okay okay
okay we're gonna talk about anything
else wait can I can I do a thing on the
average thing real quick because we we
were talking about that for real fine
okay because you can add off to you one
bit I was gonna say well it's not my
show so whatever yeah whatever's allowed
okay so what the reason why when
somebody calls somebody average that's
usually perceived to be an insult right
I think we hear it that way we give it
that way nobody's ever told somebody
that there's their average is like a
nice thing to say to somebody now we can
say that like oh well averages most
people are average kind of but also not
really right if you look at like an
average person like an average person
has 1.9 legs because some people are
missing legs but no human has 1.9 legs
you have two or one right when we look
at who we are as people there are some
things that we excel at and there are
some things that we don't do anything at
so I think that's why we never feel
average right because we're above
average hopefully at whatever our
competency is in So when you say that
somebody's average is always going to be
perceived as an insult so I'm sure that
uh Camilla or anybody else you guys all
had crazy degree you guys are all
educated than I am right I'm sure that
on a whole you might be an average
person but you're not going to perceive
yourself that way because you push
yourself forward in some areas that make
you not average and hopefully you're
looking for other people to plug into
that those above average
I just want to say it's not about even
my degree you know it's not about my
masters it's about what I've overcome
and achieved in this life that makes me
a Survivor and above average I have been
homeless on the street and I'm sitting
here today and not representing that my
struggle My Success makes me above
average and nobody can't tell me that
I'm not because if that's what I need to
tell myself to get up in the morning and
do my [__] that's what's gonna have to
happen that's who will win okay
don't talk to me like that bro
okay
stop stop stop stop I just told you to
stop I just stopped I just told you to
stop talking guys guys I was gonna give
you a chance but you can't you can't
come on Wow 30 30 seconds ago wow 30
seconds and then you
guys guys
guys
the mics are off now guys guys guys guys
guys guys
yo yo yo all right all right guys okay
okay all right thank you the first rule
of the podcast don't interrupt the horse
there we're not going to tolerate that
no more if that happens you gotta go
thank you
all right cool thank you I know I know
disrespecting stuff either thank you
okay wait wait
wait okay no no no no no stop okay thank
you
um we're gonna go on to the next
question all right all right so I'm
gonna leave okay
okay okay goodbye go go go okay because
[Music]
don't call me bro
I'm just embarrassing yourself
do you know something right do you know
something like excuse me excuse me
excuse me what's your name hello young
lady what's your name T do you know what
I'm gonna do for the first time ever I'm
gonna [__] follow you
see you later
okay okay look at look at look at your
your your issue your issue stop you're
doing it again okay oh my God
oh my God
yeah
I'll smoke you myself
[Music]
wow
okay damn right well teach you a lesson
next time you're [__] talking to your
mother yeah
[Music]
let's go
and you you need something
you you keep over to us get get get out
get out get out get out get out
how many bodies you got [__] oh my God
get out get out
get the get the [__] up get the [__] out
of my apartment get out oh my God oh my
god oh
my God
okay hold on can I just for my own
safety who are we allowed to call Bro
here and who are we not allowed to call
bro I just want to know get the [__] out
lock the blessing go lock the other side
too blessing lock the [__]
yeah the only reason was because she
kept interrupting me Jesus Christ
look it I don't oh my God
what can you go check just go go double
check go
okay
yeah but she's saying I was
disrespectful to her
yeah okay okay
guys guys guys guys guys guys guys guys
okay
okay she's gonna be like waiting outside
I was like
no that's scary that's scary I'm sorry
I'm I was scared yeah the only reason I
was gonna let her talk is the crazy
thing but she kept interrupting me and I
was just like if you're gonna keep
interrupting me you have to go like I
don't
know I don't know if she could hear you
honestly and you didn't call her name as
well no she could she could hear she
could she just kept no she I give up wow
that's true they're saying Esther's the
same one in this podcast
okay um I can't believe Auntie Jenny was
worse than me just saying okay hold on
we shouldn't should though anybody I'm
not trying to be fair I didn't think
anyone was that crazy until she started
yeah okay my next question
I actually didn't think it was that bad
but I guess I just want to know why
she's so mad that cooler broke when I
cool everyone broke it's like it's just
a respect thing man it's like your
elders like I just would never I don't
know yeah yeah it's just like I just
wouldn't call people that but I don't
think
I don't think you meant it like that no
I I think they were already upset and
then him saying bro was just like a
Timber but they were cool and they were
calling each other
it doesn't matter
yeah and I think it's because you kept
antagonizing the situation she was like
don't call me bro you're like all right
bro
when I'm speaking like it's just my
vernacular that's just how I speak in it
like so I'm leaving thinking like oh
yeah I'm trying to push her buttons like
all my thing was is that let me say
something because at this point I've
said the least out of everybody do you
get what I'm saying so I was just trying
to have Auntie said the most yeah
the show yeah but she wasn't the one
talking at that moment at that moment
exactly that's the moment I'm talking
about we're gonna I'm gonna try to go on
to the next topic yeah
yeah okay so
so yeah we're alive but that was amazing
got a lot of good Clips out of that one
okay
[Applause]
this is too much
basically yeah that was mad blessings
telling you guys to yeah
Destiny the crazy thing is I've never
had a kick out I have never I have never
I've made it a whole year almost I've
never had anyone walk out that Miami
energy back I know
oh my gosh in Miami of Europe what is
London the Miami of Europe no no
um okay
okay
I just feel like this is such a lame
question
I was gonna say can women respect a man
that they make more money than do you
guys think
I think it bring when it comes down to
actual household because I know which
you guys you guys like to have like um
subservience and dominance kind of
Dynamics I think that gets very hard
when there's an obvious Breadwinner and
I feel like
realistically whoever is making the most
money
ought to
they it will just naturally but that's
what you'd have to say you know like
I've been that person that's earned the
most money and it's about you respecting
that person not to throw it in their
face either and it's about there's
certain things that you don't even have
to spell out like I'm on 55k and you're
on 25k it's just like okay well what
we'll do for the household builds we'll
go halves but I've got the holidays and
I've got the do you know what I mean I
think you can respect but it's a choice
it makes more sense when you're more
impoverished so when there's someone
that's obviously real like you are
dependent on them for rent and food
that's when the Dynamics you can't
really have that that's the problem yeah
it's the impoverished bit I think for a
lot of these things is my wait my mic's
on right yeah okay sorry I think for a
lot of these things I think it actually
depends on how the man carries himself
right I think that if you are so like
there's I think there's a similar
question in terms of like can a woman be
with like a below average height male
right there's a guy who might be five
nine who carries himself normally and
there might be a guy who's like five
nine who acts like he's very short all
the time and I don't think people won't
like that guy but not because is he sure
because he thinks he's short same thing
with like in a household if the man is
making less money as long as the guy is
contributing well to the household and
he's not like being weird about it or
being like Moody about it I think he
could probably would you would you agree
that it's more of the exception rather
than the rule are you asking me if I
believe if numbers are real and they
exist or of course it's the exception
generally men are more than women right
now so generally yeah no because I agree
with you because I have a lot of tall
friends like super tall like I'm not I'm
not in agreement in terms of I'm gonna
say oh Lord I want to bring culture back
in here okay black Caribbean culture
I'm gonna tell you the average man
versus the average black woman right now
the black woman is anymore is that in
the the Caribbean or is that in London
or what I'm going to talk about London
Caribbean okay I can't talk about
America I can't talk about where we are
now sure because what you were saying
about the is at the average yeah I
hardly meet men that earn more than me
yeah actually
let me qualify everything anything I
would say anything anything
it's not legit man so do you do you feel
like you couldn't submit to a guy that
makes more than you okay less than you
sir less than you oh yeah I could but
again it's how he carries himself you
know what I mean I really think it's
about how young yeah and if you you it's
not even in that position because it's
about money and when you get into the
relationship I think what's mine is
yours and what's yours is mine maybe I'm
wrong but it's one pot now no and we're
all just as well yeah that's when I
first heard this conversation I was
always confused because I'm like don't
you guys have a joint bank account
doesn't it go into one that would be
ideal right yeah that's what I would
think that's right but apparently people
have joined and then they have their
yeah I found out later but like when
growing up everyone I knew always just
had a joint bank account does that mean
you've got one foot out the door then
I'm wondering in those relationships
where you have the joint but you also
got your little side monies
yeah are you fully invested in your
relationship yeah or is that your money
for a rainy day like for example I've
been told you have the joint for all
your main bills but then I have my money
to do my hair to do my nails to do my
you know whatever but
why can't I take that from the main pot
I think you should stand this right you
just like pay bills pay each other
that's what I do like like I tend to pay
a little bit more rent because I outrun
my partner so she'll just send me like I
think I rent like five grand she'll send
me like one or two thousand dollars
depending on what our agreement is and
then we'll just pay rent like that and
then everybody keeps their own money and
they do their own thing but if you want
to do like a vacation or a special thing
then depending on who's got the most
money who earns more again it's you
should it should be a team you like you
want to do things together so like like
wasn't it but why wouldn't you just have
one bank account if the problem the
problem with One bank account is we have
to be really careful about is it's easy
to lose track of spending and the last
thing you want is for money like easier
to track it yeah well it's just like
it's a thing where like nobody might
mean anything bad but maybe oh maybe
I'll I'll be sure to I'll say the woman
maybe the woman loses track of how much
like hair nails Mani Pedic costs or
whatever and then all of a sudden the
guy goes to check his bank and he's like
what the hell I'm missing like you know
500 like what's going on here and the
woman's not even thinking like oh I'm
spending all this money she's like oh I
got you know this material I'll spend it
yeah and I think that's the thing you
got to be careful of I think joint bank
accounts can work because to be really
really careful tracking like the
spending so somebody doesn't like build
resentment I think you might you might
as well just not do it you think I I
mean I don't think I should I just think
it sounds like too much of a cluster
yeah you wouldn't do it in your
relationship no really why not because
of what you just said I don't want that
confusion man yeah like come on man like
my balance just decreasing because up
here it knows
it's a collective balance decreasing huh
it's the collective balance no but like
it still doesn't work I just think it's
confusion we'd have to keep receipts
track of everything like nah I think if
both parties are making a lot of money I
think it's okay because you guys are
rich or whatever but when you're like
paycheck man if you're like you know
three or four days out from Payday and
your account is broke and you want to go
out and get you know just like some kind
of food and then you go and check in the
last four charges where something a girl
did yeah you're I don't care what kind
of man you are you're gonna be president
even if even if you spent more you're
gonna be pissed off because you're going
to see me like oh that's going to be
tense it's going to be tense who do you
guys think benefited more from the win
women's sexual Liberation movement or
the sexual Liberation movement
I would say men men and it's annoying
because in any scenario men still always
benefit even before women got their
sexual Liberation men still benefited
now they've got their sexual Liberation
men are still benefiting I don't think
so I mean I didn't why do you think men
benefit I'm just curious the reason I
think men benefit is because now men
don't have to do a lot now to get sex so
literally go on a dating app a woman's
coming even now women don't even get
their ears paid anymore they'll be like
I'll drive to you because I need some D
now what is done now is creating
unrealistic expectations for
relationships so now as a woman you want
a man to whine and die new and six to
nine you
but I feel like now it's like men don't
need to do that anymore because you can
just get sex somewhere else is that
because I'm liberated or because the the
Traditional Values have gone I think
Liberation in the promiscuity manner
know that's what I'm I'm speaking upon
obviously like I'm I would say to us to
an extent I'm sexually liberated because
of the fact that I I feel like I can
have sex with whoever I want but this is
a person that I want to be with it's not
just somebody that I saw on the street
and because he's fine I'm gonna let him
put something inside me no it's because
I respect this man I want to see a
future with him you know it's somebody I
actually see myself with but I think a
lot of women now it's just I'm horny you
know what let me give it to any man and
I feel like that is just give it to just
any man breath a lot of women
I apologize
but I think like a lot of times like
you're saying yeah you're liberated and
all this but it's not like women are not
just going around throwing it to just
any guy out there because there's loads
of guys that are not getting any books
and you don't always forget that every
single time you have these conversations
yeah we always quote the 40 of men that
are not getting sex right yeah you don't
care about you're not in that category
I'm really sorry but Society already
helps you like men that you can get sex
on a palatter you can get a prostitute
but you know actually what people never
actually say they say 40 men report to
not be having sex but what they don't
report is they're not not having sex
because of women it's because they don't
feel confident in themselves so actually
I actually saw the report it was saying
things like I've had a lot of things
sorry they reported things like I've had
a lot of chances but because I didn't
feel like I was going to do it right and
they said the reason that they feel this
insecurity is because of social media
and you know social mediences really
because if I have a small Willy then I'm
not taking it out but I feel like
so you're saying these guys have women
that are down they're ready to sleep
with them okay okay wait so these 40
Birds let me just that yeah I just want
to make sure what they say okay you're
telling me these 40 of men have guys or
girls girls not guys girls ready to
sleep with them and they're just saying
you know what I don't feel good about
myself I'm not going to no I'm not
saying so many women want to have sex
with them I'm saying these same men
reported that they've been in situations
where they could have had sex but they
didn't feel confident in themselves to
say you know what I can do this right
but and you know whether insecurity
actually comes from other men men go out
talking about their game okay oh I've
got this you know I can pull any girl it
makes other men actually feel insecure
in themselves when actually in reality
women will have sex with any man as long
as you fulfill her needs it doesn't have
to be sexual it could be emotional need
it could speak for yourself
any oh no but in this time if this guy
made you fall like a queen email I'm
sorry I'm a tall girl I'm a tall girl
I'm six foot right it doesn't matter how
good a 5'5 guy makes me feel right
[Applause]
if I was shorter it'd be different but
I'm tall like but that's cute you could
just like okay you guys can do that
that's fine I'm not but the thing is
aren't you single are you single
yeah yeah then what what input do you
have on any of those what do you think
is it one of your big rows so like women
have standards that are too high and
they're not being realized blah blah
blah blah now you're looking for a guy
that's what six one at least
five five Destiny
that's what I said that's like 50
standard deviations
[Laughter]
five five sorry
you do this when people are talking
we're supposed to speak about for
everybody but then when every time you
give an example you go to like the
eighth standard deviation away from the
norm yeah how many guys are five five
it's like less than one okay yeah look
at five seven you know
you think it benefited man what do you
think Destiny uh I think there's pros
and cons to everybody that's gonna be
the same for everything it's nice for
women because women can have more sex
without necessarily getting pregnant and
having kids women have a little bit more
Independence so they can explore
sexually without being tied down to one
man that they have to marry for men
there is more availability of sex I know
there was that 140 number but I think
that was uh quoted I want to say in 2021
it was like when the pandemic was crazy
and everything I think that fell I don't
know what it fell to
um but I mean like yeah like sex is more
available now than it was in the past
for most people which is but there's
pros and cons right there's going to be
more competition for sex there's going
to be more competition for relationships
back 30 40 50 years ago all a man had to
do was work a job and he was basically
like guaranteed a wife because women
couldn't work
um yeah I think it's important to
recognize or pros and cons to everything
can I point something out a lot of the
time you guys talk about this 80 20
ratio that like women are all gunning
for the same man and like
those studies that you
um reference they're all based on dating
apps like Okay Cupid and Tinder and I
just want to say like dating in the real
world is far different to our choices on
Tinder like there could be a perfect man
on a hinge and I will see lives in
dagenham
that is true that is true I'm crazy I'm
crazy on them as because everyone but if
someone is in front of me that that I
get along with and I can learn to love
then all this nonsense of marketization
and all this
writing yourself it's absolutely
this one is we swipe right on dating
apps what five percent of the time what
do you mean yeah but that's because wait
wait wait let me so so even if we we
triple it quadruple it that's still only
20 we could double it make it 40 it's
five to one men to women on these apps
of course women are going to be highly
selected
highly and women are highly selective in
real life as well they're absolutely not
not as much as men as much as
Mission question do you do you think
Matt who's pick your men or women when
it comes to what when it comes to four
relationships for relationships I think
men tend to gatekeep relationships more
for sex women tend to get sex you think
men are equally picky when it comes to
relationships or sex that's
relationships well it's important
because you guys mix them up a lot
sure okay for relationships I think men
can keep more than women do no I'm
asking if you think they're equally
picky with the women that they want to
be in relationships with as women are to
men
um
are men as women so so for you if you
were gonna if you were gonna I mean
you're already married right and I'm I'm
looking for a husband and you're looking
for a wife who's pickier typically by
and large I'm not not like I'm just
using it I think it's I think it's
roughly equal really that's so
interesting it's interesting but the
reason why is because you guys get all
your information from dating from dating
apps where the numbers are super skewed
but if you go into any school all the
boys are dating all the girls if you go
into any workplace
all the girls in their environments
where men and women are together look at
the YouTube world every YouTubers
that's how it works but the problem is
you guys are only looking at like well
look at Tinder where it's five men to
one I don't actually agree on college
campuses it's similar I would say it's
similar on college campuses there's like
a select group of men that tend to do
very well no hold on wait no no wait you
okay what you just said is a highlight
of why I think you're not either
engaging no no wait because you said men
do very well
can I just I said a select group of men
you said so for example like athletes no
one athlete is not dating five women a
select group of men they might have sex
but that's why I say it's important to
distinguish sex between relationships an
elite group of men can [__] a lot of
women sure only a group of women
yeah sure can I ask you a question okay
I'm not I'm not saying in terms of
relationships I'm saying in the initial
encounters where men come together with
women we're not even talking about
relationships now we're just that
initial moment when they meet who's
usually going to be more pickier who's
who's going to be more willing to like
settle with whatever comes their way
whatever you know they catch that night
or whenever they meet in in their real
life yeah when you've got to be more
who's going to be more picky picky
no I think no no no listen listen listen
before the sex or the relationship has
come yeah you first have to meet that
person and you subconsciously you know
in your mind not even subconsciously you
know in your mind if I would sleep with
that person or I would give them a
chance you already know that in your
mind when you look at them bro like so
what I'm saying sorry I shouldn't have
called you bro
but what I'm saying is that in in that
initial moment when you first come into
contact with the opposite sex here who
is usually more picky is it going to be
men or women that's what I'm asking I'm
not asking the relationship down the
road sure when you think you're just sex
men are gonna be less picky than women
of course attractions
sorry can I just um say something so in
terms of sex and relationship it's so
different because men they would pick
anyone to to have sex with because men
just have a high sex drive but when it
comes to relationship I believe men are
a lot more picky they'll say they don't
want a woman that has too much body
count they don't want a woman with kids
uh a woman with kids
women the Senate that we set for
ourselves is literally does he treat me
well is he gonna be a good father yeah
before you get to that point there's a
there's a yes or no before you get to
that point of I would like to get in a
relationship with this guy you already
that guy would have to qualify some
requirements some preferences in the
first place and now you don't have to
have sex to do that
speak I never said you have to have sex
yeah but women will speak to anyone
yes and yes and women will speak to guys
and they'll be banging the guy that they
really like yeah
and they will and they will want
relationships from that guy
this is this is what I think this is
when we talk about gatekeeping sex
versus relationships this is what I
think okay if you were to go into a
guy's body count and you were to ask the
guy if the last 10 women you [__]
which of those 10 would you date I think
you can find guys that would say like
one or two maybe but if you go and you
ask a girl the last five or ten guys you
banged how many of them would you date
they'd say like well three of them I did
date you know and for the most part like
at least half of them I'd probably
consider dating right yeah that's what I
mean when I say generally like men will
get keep the relationship part a little
bit definitely yeah yeah that's exactly
what I'm saying you know I said I agreed
I said I wasn't argument and you just
kept talking he wasn't listening
I was agreed with you no you were no I
say it initially before that even you're
starting to go out on dates and you're
considering a relationship you need to
that person has to qualify certain
requirements and usually it's a looks
test the looks test will really
determine how far or how much um
allowance or how many how many chances
you're going to give to this guy not
really as well
because let's be wrong
every guy that approaches you you you
accept their advances I'm not saying I
like I accept every single Advance I'm
just saying women are very realistic
with their options like they know that
nowadays
let me finish yeah we can say oh yeah I
want a six foot guy but they know
there's not that many things when it
comes to reality yeah
it's the Dunya out here like bro they
are frogs everywhere you actually women
actually stop and thinking know what I
don't want to be single for the rest of
my life I want to be married
and what age and what age do they start
thinking like to be felt a lot when
they're older
so when they're out of their prime years
but men never men always think they can
get the bad guy Shake you've got to be
rude I'm not trying to be rude I'm not
trying to be rude but at the end of the
day your Prime music
not in reality it hits them in the face
because they're not gonna get that girl
but the girl can still sleep with that
guy okay you're so millbrained and all
your answers you're only looking at the
sex most women know they could [__] most
guys whatever they want that's why women
don't chase sex they don't need to it is
there's always that number that's why I
get mad when you guys talking about
hypergamy like an average whatever woman
who knows
because you'll make like three different
numbers
do you not think women date up no no no
no no no not now
this is a data answer when you say date
up you're only looking at it from the
male perspective when you say data you
go oh well they date up because the men
is earning more money but then you'll
say things like men value younger women
and in that case men date up because
they tend to date younger
we all value different things in the
dating Market everybody
in the exchange of that that man that
has got all the money and resources and
all that to offer the woman and the
woman's basically she's young good
looking do you think that's an even
exchange of value yes because the man is
chasing what he wants the woman's
chasing what she wants so is he dating
down no it's not dating down
if you want a prime minute you want a
young body that height
he'll say men don't care about a woman's
accomplishments and then you'll say well
a guy is dating a woman that's young and
super hot they're like oh he's dating
down no no it's not dating down because
you just said they don't care about the
words
because in that exchanger the man is
probably offering resources and
protection yeah protection and provision
that is long lasting that's forever what
whereas what that woman is offering is
her Youth and her beauty which will
disappear
no I'm just saying it's I'm saying it's
not as even you're saying it's an even
exchange but it's not because he's
offering something that is forever and
she's offering something that will
disappear in like what Seven Ten Years
companionship no but that's not the
point
that's not what we're talking about
right but in that scenario at that point
that's what he values at that point how
values
listen listen listen listen you're
talking about loving all that I'm just
saying on the best no no no I'm not
talking about love I'm talking about in
terms of what men value they don't value
a woman that makes a lot of money okay
you said that yourself okay so in that
moment in time they value younger women
okay so he's not dating down because it
is what you're not thinking you're not
thinking and the whole scope of it okay
yes I agree with you and I said it yes
men will value Youth and fertility and
all of them things but these are all
things that disappear
no no no no no no you're not you're not
America no that's the man no no no okay
Finish finish you're not listening what
he's offering does not disappear it
doesn't go it doesn't go nowhere
the man Chester what they value right if
they value younger women and that's what
they want at that moment it doesn't
matter if it expires in a couple years
I want a woman that is stable and can
give his children all that they need his
his needs might probably change
everything is everything in this life is
fleeting you don't own all your material
yes you have resources now listen Okay
but that can disappear what's more
likely look at the economy now look at
him hyperin happen one day certainly all
this is gone yeah but you're saying
maybe you're saying maybe you're talking
about May these
you don't want anything you're not
listening you're just over talking me
and you're not listening and this I know
what you're saying that so what am I
saying that our Beauty here is
inevitable that it will 100 100 yeah I'm
saying you're talking about oh nothing
you don't owe nothing in this world and
what if this happens it's what if you're
talking about I understand okay okay but
what I'm getting at is that just because
certain possessions we have may
disappear does not mean our value as a
human being diminishes what is important
is us as individuals having a
partnership and love like all this stuff
wait wait
we have to go one at a time because when
you're talking over each other it's just
it's hard to hear on the audio okay well
I just wait I didn't say talk yet
um
I just wonder what you're I think you're
you've got a very juvenile standard of
beauty
because you're beautiful you're gonna
say that and I'm saying that because I
can I can give you let's look at
Celebrities
is just as beautiful as she is at 50.
you're not the market
I just you should maybe you should ask
men because it's men that's gonna date
her man that's gonna marry her men that
will impregnate her are you telling me
for all men bro
I'm in a better position than you I'm
not sure you know because you're as I
said you're talking from a very juvenile
unmatured perspective of what beauty is
okay
so there's some girl I don't know who
that is what's her name Nia Long Nia
Long and she's just as beautiful at 20
or at 50 if she is at 20. I believe so
okay
[Laughter]
what do you think
uh people date for different things at
different ages this is like a really
kind of silly conversation like an older
guy might value a woman because she's
young and beautiful but as you start
dating hopefully you start to appreciate
other things and then a relationship
goes from that if you want a family can
you ask the looks thing like do you
think most women look better at 50 or
the same time probably not but people at
50 are dating for different things okay
right
I didn't see most women well they should
be but unfortunately a lot of men they
do want younger women it is quite fat
and I think it's quite sickening
sir I have a question do you think it's
equally sad and sickening that women
want successful men
is it sad and sickening then I like talk
I would I mean when I say sick I mean
like a 50 year old one in today a 20
something year old like dude man you've
been through generations why do you find
a 20 something year old attractive
you've been through life to me I'm not
going to lie that is a bit if you if you
want a young guys in like 10 years
younger that's okay you know she's
experienced she's been through a lot but
when you're going like as far as 20
something to me that's crazy and you
need to have conversations with yourself
I'm not gonna lie but in terms of
wanting money I I don't even I don't
even encourage women to go for a man for
money even that I don't encourage
because I I do think that's it's all
very fictitious to me I think women
should just go for things that make them
happy rather than like materialistic
things but unfortunately some women do
like that so I can't really tell people
what's her life if you have the same
energy yeah yeah I think I find that I
feel like you should go out there as a
woman you we are so blessed with
feminism this is why honestly I don't
know why people speak down on feminism
we can make our own money bro in Africa
in certain countries women can't do that
so to me it's just such a blessing that
women can do that and in Western
countries I don't know why women don't
want it why are you still looking for a
man to take care of you but if that's
what you like because they want a soft
life
yeah but you can give yourself the soft
life don't tell me where we can go into
managerial roles you can work hard get
your money up they don't want to they
don't want to though
well it seems like they do because they
are more than they ever have in all of
history right definitely yeah but
there's a lot of them that still want a
man that's making way more money than
them and a lot of times a lot of women
that are yeah they're making all this
money they still want a guy that's gonna
be taking on financial burden yeah
that's true but those numbers are
changing I think it was like it was like
38 I think in like 2017 or 2015 like for
people that wanted for women still
wanting them to out or no but that
number slowly come down over time it'll
probably adjust as more people make it's
more money you have to wait for society
to adjust
all right you do your thing but we're
gonna wait yeah I mean I don't care what
you do
I haven't said anything that's
unrealistic the world is moving in the
direction that you are asking so like
all this complaining and complaining
what I've complained about oh how oh
women want to date men that are making
more I never I never said that as a
complaint I was just stating but the
obvious but I'm saying but you're saying
it's a complaint no no I'm saying that
so you're going to adjust what you're
saying no no listen I'm saying that it's
already changing okay but I wasn't
complaining though okay well that's fine
then I'm just saying I don't know why
you thought I was complaining
women can't win if they want a man that
makes a lot of money you're gold digger
if you want a man that's average or
whatever she's not she's not um like
thinking high enough she should respect
herself she says that oh actually there
was a video that went viral it was
actual Kendra we were just like every
time a girl says she needs has high
standards literally girls always cheer
her on
no no no no no no no no no when I like I
think there was it was actually a video
that went very recently where it was on
Kendra G's uh Instagram live and it was
this woman she said I date broke men I
do not care I love broke men and she
said all a man needs to have is 2 000
like 2 000 a month that's all he needs
to earn and in the comments people were
saying oh you don't even respect
yourself you shouldn't I'm sure they did
that women can't win
I'm just thinking on the internet
everyone's gonna complain yeah but I
mean everybody does that like they say
like women will always have each other
but men do it too you'll see like a form
full of like no offense but like super
fat really nerdy loser guys who are like
[__] on women who are like a million
times more attractive than any woman
they'll ever talk to right that's where
like the pointy elbows mean comes from
right yeah because even that happened to
me on sauce cast I forgot what number I
said when they said like the salary but
they're like [__] on me for it was
like it wasn't even low either it was
like I don't know 55 number for what
like they asked me what salary I would
date and all the girls were like oh no
you need to make it higher but I was
like wow
that's what I mean there will always be
someone that comes just do whatever
makes you happy that's just life though
like people complain especially if
you're like you're gonna be on the
internet yeah you can do yeah you can
you can do whatever makes you happy but
if you lose don't complain in it
because there's a little winner that's a
fair game don't complain yeah but I
think men and no one has to give you a
no one has to give you sympathy because
when I when I do my reaction videos to
these chicks I'm saying chicks grown
women grown overgrown women that flip in
they're crying over Chad and Tyrone oh
he left me blah blah I always say I have
no sympathy for you because you're an
adult and you made choices and I think
that everyone has to be accountable for
their choices simple but do you say the
same thing yes and I talk crap about
guys too when a man a man goes for a
woman that only wants him for money yeah
do you say you made that you need to say
you should understand if you're if
you're getting into a situation with a
woman who is only there for your money
like for instance your example of the
guy that's 50 years old getting with a
21 year old girl obviously that he's not
you're not her first choice bro like do
you get what I'm saying so like yeah you
should understand the situation you're
in understand the dynamic that bro she's
there because you have money and she's
young hot girl now if you if your 50
year old man and think oh she really he
loves me because she she helped me bust
nuts you're an idiot and that's it but
the thing is I think guys are more
inclined to just deal with reality
whereas women you know you are brought
up with the whole Disney Cinderella
Sleeping Beauty rhetoric that kind of
messes you lot up and you you think oh
yeah the first Chad on Tyrone I meet
like out of school whatever we're gonna
have some kind of relationship and he's
hot blah blah no brother no no
and then it's when you get to like 30
years old now you want a nice guy now
you want a good guy he doesn't have to
be tall he doesn't have to be rich I
just want a guy that's going to be there
loyal come on bro I don't think so I
think sorry
Destiny I have a question for you why do
you think that college were college
educated women initiate divorce 90 of
the time
uh well I don't know what are the stats
say isn't it that usually people aren't
happy in their relationships
um
hence what study you look at I've looked
at like
um sometimes it's Financial sometimes
I've seen infidelity I think as a high
one I've seen people are just generally
not happy with the relationship
um differences
that's mine as well
I was just curious anecdotally
I don't know very many divorces with
college degrees so I can't really say no
oh
why do you what do they say
I mean I don't ask them they're like my
mom's friends I don't go I don't ask
them for the behind the scenes of their
divorces
do you feel like do you asking that
question you feel like something in
college makes
women women
no I mean I feel like women just have a
hard time
I mean I think it kind of goes back to
like women out earning men have a hard
time respecting the men they're with
that's not true that's not true that's
not true I actually read it again
it's not true I read into that data and
he explained why so a lot of times the
women reported that they had way too
much responsibility in the marriage so
they were expected to be in charge of
the household duties and still work a
job and they added oh come on what
percent of modern women actually cook it
was it was that is
20 of the men when both parents are
working only 20 actually reported to
doing household duties that's scary when
you're both working I'm just saying the
shit's automated nowadays I mean you
have a washing machine a dishwasher yeah
but as much as it's on as much as it's
on a Minute Men still don't do it yes
when you get older and you manage a
household on your own Pearl you'll see
how [__] annoying it is when you're
working and then you come home and
everything is [__] up and horrible and
nobody's [__] cleaning anything yeah
that is a totally valid reason for
divorce of course yeah chores to break
up a home our family have you lived in a
filthy hole
if it is consistent where you'll
consistently having to have that burden
upon yourself you keep telling them
please can you clean up like it's so
funny because like lifelong friends from
like grade school to high school well
dormant college and then hate each other
forever over like bad dorm roommates and
that's not even a relationship so yeah
of course I think stuff like this is
perfectly valid I think I think
splitting up and splitting up splitting
up duties in the households like what
are the most important parts of like a
relationship because it's where you're
spending most of the time together
that's why I say people get triggered
when I say I don't think you're even
dating until you live together because
until you live together you don't really
know who the other person's like and
once you start living together and you
see what the household duties are like
then you get a feel for what the
relationship is I mean I just I just
think that like I don't know I feel like
that stuff can be worked out chores like
hold on wait do you understand wait wait
hold on wait you're not saying anything
oh you do this intentionally we're like
I don't know about that we're telling
you I'm telling you that I mean I mean
you're giving your opinion I'm giving
I'm not giving an opinion I'm saying
that in a house so there's not an
opinion I'm putting as far as fact in a
house delineation of chores is one of
the most important things that if
somebody's constantly destroying the
bathroom leaving clothes everywhere
leaving dirty food in the sink they
can't clean their their dishes or
whatever like these things will it will
destroy anything over time yeah but
that's what that's what she said she
said I'm sure we can work it out
there may be maybe these women that are
making all this money that you know
they're making so much money working
they don't want to do the house chores
maybe they should go and get an older
guy with more money so they can go
unemploy a maid
yeah you guys maybe they should do that
thing man how's that anyway but you've
got a problem no you want listen to what
you just said you said they're leaving
the guys that make less money because
they're expected to make money and do
the house and you're saying how hard it
is because you're at home and you're
doing all these shows okay then don't be
with a guy that makes less money find
the guy that makes more money and then
you don't have to do chores because you
employed a maid and a cook okay but then
like you said but then young guys young
guys can't complain then that girls
won't date their own age because they
because guys can't do house chores then
you'd be like oh sorry you know you're
25 years old you have to be single to
your 35 and learn how to do the dishes
five percent of men can even afford that
to be like oh yeah
and what percentage of and what
percentage of women are these high flyer
women that are making six figures a year
no I'm not no I'm not okay no I'm just
asking I'm just asking you I'm just
asking you because you're going you're
making this point about these women that
make so much money and then they're
making they make so much money
they work so having a full-time job on
average men or women are going to into
what they're in the workforce so
obviously they're making money I'm not
saying that high earners all I'm saying
is they're working that's it okay so the
the solution is men should understand
that their women are also working so how
can I help knowing that we're doing the
same job how can I make her life easy
because she's making my life easy by
doing the chores well said that but
Pearl said that I'm sure there's a way
you could work it out so that the house
chores can be you know easy and good for
everybody
let me ask a question do you think so do
you think the man should do the house
tools because he makes less money yeah
most of them most of them yes most of
them cool okay do you why do you think
they're getting divorced do you think
divorce is fun that the because they're
college educated and they hate men
they're just like I'm just gonna divorce
because I I hate all men like why do you
think I get a divorced I think women
divorce for no reason all the time
that's absolutely [__] you just need
to talk to more people then because
that's not true
days a week
if you think that people just get
divorcedure on the street
you've never seen my street interviews
then I've done so many Street interviews
I talked to random strangers on the
street all the time and you and you find
women that get divorced like oh you know
I just wanted to get divorced yeah but
the reasons
oh my God you're actually a child what
do you think love is you're just like
romantically going away to Venice like
every year and that's like like no
relationship requires a lot of
deliberate work and things like hold on
hold on things like chores are where
relationships start to break down and
it'll steamroll into bigger things like
a guy not doing Choice ever might be a
guy that you don't want to [__] anymore
and then you not having sex ever it
might be you guys just don't get along
anymore and then like three months into
it you [__] hate each other and you
don't know why and you're not sleeping
together even you're not having any sex
you don't do anything together and it
starts over small [__] but anybody
that's been in any relationship long
term I don't know how old you guys are
but if you've been in real relationships
long term these little things will pile
up and [__] kill you they're like the
worst things relationships are not like
this puppy like romantic love constantly
it's doing the small things every single
day to make sure the relationships work
yep okay but you're just like lol chores
like I don't know what that means I just
think that like why do you have to let
it get to that point I feel like it's
the guys that aren't doing the chores
you think it's controversial to say that
I think chores is a crazy reason to get
divorced and break up a home and put
your kid at every statistical
disadvantage that you possibly could no
because it's not just a choice I just
think that's a stupid if you can't do a
choice you probably can't pick your kid
up on time you probably aren't paying
attention to the needs of your [__]
wife okay you probably aren't keeping
other parts like if you can't do chores
everything else in life is probably
falling apart you should have picked a
better guy and then you know what I need
divorce then you divorce once you have
kids it's not about you anymore I mean I
don't really know if someone's get
divorced fired but like I just think
once you have kids it's not about you
you can't help me stop using this excuse
of just pick a better guy as a as a
answer every time women aren't happy
about situation can we just hold men
accountable and just say please can you
help your woman out okay okay I'll help
you they don't have enough options
thank you wow
my whole
house
faster my whole argument is that I think
divorce is stupid over chores I think
that's stupid
I feel like you've never lived with
someone that like she hasn't like that's
the only thing that's the only way you
don't understand you've never lived with
somebody that is like you come home so
tired you know you've cleaned the house
you're ready to just sleep in your bed
and the house is a pigstylist it's funny
was you in a relationship with a bum
then no you've done it so you sound like
you've done it have you been in that
situation I'm not gonna I'm not gonna go
into that detail now but you're you're
talking about like Pearl hasn't done it
so obviously if you're if you're talking
from that standpoint it sounds like you
have experience that's all I'm asking oh
so you've done it then
no
okay so you're basically in the same
position
because you're in the same position
I think it's really funny I think it's
really funny that when we have these
conversations we say LOL just chores
Ella will just chores but then when I go
on any red pill podcast and I say what
is a perfect wife what's a perfect woman
the only thing that the men say are
women that do chores I want a woman that
takes care of the house that cooks me a
clean meal that makes sure that my home
is in order those are chores that's all
that is King there's other relationships
than just men and women I've lived with
other people and I know who I'm talking
about okay that's just because it's
normal but we're talking about something
specific though now we're talking about
the chaos of not doing chores in the
house and what that brings to your home
your home is supposed to have peace
everybody's fighting I understand that
but we're talking about something
specific though all right thanks and
also just to add on if 90 of college
student women are initiating divorces
that means
a lot wait what's wrong with my mind
you turn your head you're not like you
have to move like you've got to be
freaking like right covering my face
no you gotta you gotta lift it by like
that yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah push it
down yeah yeah that's it thank you again
there
just put it just put it down just face
it towards you it doesn't move like that
like that it does move it just knocks me
out it's like it's Gonna Knock we've got
loads of hinges there yeah yeah come on
bro you got this
see what I mean it just moves
awkward
there we go yeah thank you okay okay
don't touch it well yeah the point I
wanted to make is if 90 of college
students women are basically initiating
the divorce that means there are a lot
of men that are bombs do you not think
no it just means you probably make bad
choices
so those 90 all of them made bad choices
well I agree but it's the men and women
making bad choices if we say that right
well she's not she's not saying that oh
she's not saying that bro don't help her
okay
I just feel like when when the stats are
so high like if it was like 60 you can
say it's just you can put it down just
the bad choices but when it's 90 I never
said all though I just said a lot
yeah but it's also proven that a lot of
men are bombs is it is that right yeah
because a lot of women are feeling the
same way because you feel because women
feel a certain way that means it makes
it a fact
what if they're reporting it a lot of
women are reporting to say what exactly
they're reporting that one of the
reasons that they've initiated divorce
are things like the man's not
understanding helping out with other
responsibilities that's one that's one
aspect yeah exactly but that's what you
think do you think the women do you
think the women that uh just choose men
over superficial things and when it
doesn't work out because he's a Chad and
Tyrone and he cheats do you think they
they add that to the list as well do
they do they come out with
accountability and say you know what I
picked horribly I picked the guy because
he was six foot six and he had a big
Willy do you think they put that down as
well no of course they wouldn't of
course exactly so you're you're only
hyper focused on one thing your hyper
focused because we've been talking about
for the last 20 minutes this one aspect
okay let's talk about something else so
another reason that they reported
initiating the divorce is because they
don't have to tolerate bad behavior back
in the days bad behavior so back in the
days women went through a lot of abuse
Financial abuse emotional abuse because
of the fact that they didn't have
Financial Security they married just to
get that Financial Security and now
their college bro they're going to earn
a lot of money when when they graduate
so now it's like I don't need you to
really rely on I don't need to rely on
you for financial support I can actually
make decisions because of the way I feel
now now you're not making me happy
you're not trying to make me happy so
I'm just gonna leave I've tried to come
like communicate with you and we're not
getting anywhere so now it's really
because women can
okay let me ask you this question yeah
in a comparison of men and women in
relationships who do you think is easier
to please
be real man be real who's easier to
please
you know the answer everyone knows the
answer everyone knows the answer I think
men are more simple yeah
and you knew that as soon as I asked
yeah you knew the answer so it's so with
that knowledge when we all understand
that women are probably more complicated
and complex than it's gonna be harder to
please her because a lot of times like
you lots opinions and feelings change
like the wind blows right like it's
gonna be a hard task to keep that person
happy majority of the time
are you trying though are you trying
that's the point if they're just like
literally leaving their marriage just
because they're just not happy that's
that's nonsense but if they're actually
trying to communicate it and the man is
just it's not getting anywhere then
there's a problem there that means this
woman is actually trying to communicate
how she feels and the reason you might
think women are hard to please is
because you men are so used to not
listening to women it's such a normal
thing to just say she's crazy everyone
listens to women what are you talking
about no you don't okay everyone okay
okay in our current Society yes everyone
does listen to women no people don't
listen to men even men don't listen to
other men what you just heard what I
said in certain okay exercise
and some areas of life men are
completely bought out of it so one thing
about where I'm what I'm studying I
cannot stand the hatred of what this men
all the time being the reason for
everything being terrible I feel like
you guys get a very bad rep and there's
no communication as everything is always
your guys's fault and that reductive uh
um view on life does not actually get us
anywhere so in that respect I agree with
you that men are not listened to at all
in a lot of areas to the point where I
feel like there's going to be no men
left in Academia other than like
engineering and Sciences there's no
nobody is going to be wanting to study
literature because what we're talking
about is it's just degrading them in a
way that is it's just terrible can I can
I go to one of your classes with you oh
my gosh
why do you think Society why do you
think Society is not listening to men
the richest most successful in the world
are men
so it's a small percentage of men that
what percent of men are in those roles
yeah yeah that's like saying that might
like it's at least like 90 something
percent that are in that leadership role
so oh
man you listen to a small percentage of
men
okay
stop cutting me off I go okay what what
percent of men are in those leadership
positions what percent of men are in
those positions well in terms of ratio
and it's about 90 something percent two
women so I'm saying what percent of men
out of 100 men you meet what percent of
men are in positions of power that's not
the point okay
just because you don't like the question
you have to answer the question what
percent of men out of 100 men what
percent of men are in those positions
but that's not the point no no answer
because she's trying to say what she's
trying to say that we don't know because
she when we say we don't listen
by and large it's saying we don't listen
to men as a whole there's a small
percentage of men that are in power yes
and often times
so okay come out of every 100 men you
meet on the street what percent of those
men are in Parliament
answer answer the question
if you don't want to answer the question
you can leave
I want to ask you a question you can
leave it's not that dude
it's not a personal question so you can
answer it okay we'll say the top 20.
okay do you think two out of every 10
men you meet two are in Parliament no
not in Parliament in power okay okay
fine fine we'll go with that so how how
does 20 of men represent men as a whole
yeah but if there's 90 something percent
there's more representation than for
women so when we're talking about
listening the people we are we seem to
be listening to amen right but I'm
saying that don't stop making decisions
for society that doesn't represent the
average man and we all we use this to
make Envy of them and this is why we not
listening to them and this is this is
why it's manifesting in these terrible
figures of Andrew Tay and sneak on all
these people are trying to emulate this
kind of masculinity because they feel
like they're not being heard these are
the only reasons why these men exist and
now we'll have women being human
trafficked and everybody's now listening
to women because we've taken over the
conversation
I mean me and Destiny we did a uh uh
reaction video earlier to Andrew Tate's
uh documentary and I asked Destiny like
why do you think so many guys like
listen to Andy Tate or resonate or you
know follow his his um lead and like you
know it's a lot of guys you know they're
looking for that leadership they're
looking for somebody like a father
father figure like a role model to to
kind of you know stand behind because
they feel like they're they're the guys
they're the demographic that is not
being heard to get what I'm saying
whereas like if you look at current
Society like it is actually it's
actually more geared for women to be in
positions of like you know uh changing
the the mindset of people do you get
what I'm saying no it is
that doesn't change no but listen those
people okay yeah you're right you're
right you're right all right let's run
with that yeah there's men this is
predominantly men that make the laws
legislation yeah yeah we're correct yeah
okay uh tell me one law that favors men
over over women right now
they don't need there doesn't need to be
a law question bro answer the question
just please you can say whatever you
want but answer the question first okay
okay okay
there's not a lot of laws that favors
men because they don't they don't need
to really come up with laws like that so
in terms of
um what's a law in terms of child
support right so a lot of the time a
woman is going to get the child and
she's going to get the child support
right why even though sometimes even
though even the society and Society men
seem to not want to take care of their
children because Society favors men so
there actually has to be things in place
rules in place to enforce it's
definitely not
um I feel Society has cast everything
masculine as toxic and that's why that's
not true even in this conversation when
they were taught she was talking about
how men like younger women they called
it ageist yeah and all I did was ask her
but why do we have to every time we make
a statement about men we have to say but
so are women
so we have to because no we have to talk
about women we can there are things that
women struggle with yes that's true but
we're talking about men's struggles
right now and it's like we always have
to put a butt women yeah
it's like it's like Esther you you get
heard plenty oh I promise you you get
hurt
you get
you
get invited me why
good teacher
but but the whole point is like why is
it every time we bring up a men's issue
we have to bring up women's
but if we bring up women's issues it's
not butt men we don't see that I think
the problem is because when these
communities exist it feels like none of
you guys can ever like talk about your
issues without constantly deriding the
other side like you yourself when you
did that big interview with I don't know
if it was the vice panel you said oh I
think women have it easier than men I do
yeah overall that's great okay that's
fine but the issue is that every time
these like sub-communities form they
seem to not ever be able to focus on
themselves they constantly have to throw
the other side of the bus too like there
are ways in life there are areas in life
where women absolutely have a use of the
bed you bring up things like the draft
right or expecting to stay home and work
whatever but there are other things
where men have it way easier too when we
talk about legislation for instance it
like favors uh man over women the
easiest thing I can think of the United
States is abortion if men got pregnant
you could get an abortion on every gas
station Corner Block in the United
States with no questions asked
guaranteed because it's a woman's issue
we talk about it in a way different
light I think that there are it's free
up to six months here
hold on oh my God wait is my mic on okay
because I thought I said in America and
you just totally ignored that and we're
both American so I don't know why you
said that okay yeah so yeah
I don't know why you brought up London
because you did that no no you were
being polite you totally just pivoted
you accused her being that famous but
this is like I I'm I'm being very
pleased I've been polite too the whole
time sure well you just can't start
being that faith that I said in America
that's an example of a law and then
you're like well here in London I don't
know what it is okay okay but to be
honest with you it was me that asked the
question and I'm oh yeah sure I'm just
saying that everybody everybody has
their issues and it's hard to ever say
like one like you guys even talked about
earlier this is a common red building
who is like more accountability who is
take more accountability men can turn
their lives around way easier than a
woman can right like a guy can go
through all sorts of stuff be in jail
kill people get shot do all these things
and at 35 come out like a reform guy
okay a woman gets pregnant at 24 and now
she's got too much mileage for any guy
in here to ever want to [__] with right
so I think there's just different ways
there you couldn't even give that little
bit you couldn't even give it a little
bit right no I tried to trick I was
tricky you did it you triggered me you
did yeah
others get married all the time it's
single hold on you just did it again
single being a single mother sucks yeah
everybody here agrees it so why even say
that single mothers get married no
because you said it you said it was over
you said it seemed like and maybe I'm
misconstruing you so please don't go
crazy on me but it's like at at 24 you
said it's over if she has too many miles
that's what you guys weren't more more
miles for any guy to to [__] with her
and I said no that's not true mothers
get married all like remarried all the
time sure they might get remarried but
you're dating selection if you're a
single mother
correct it's significantly lower than it
was yeah your options are different
but wait wait but wait wait but most
single mothers can still date an average
guy yeah and most average guys still
date average women
um you can't even admit that and it's
true it's true I'm so sorry but it's
absolutely true
questions
you're telling me out here that single
mothers are having an easier time than
average guys I don't but okay I was
gonna ask the two ladies that uh lift
you I'll actually put it as well easier
but okay you did do you think do you
think like
um women do you think the majority of
women find the majority of men
attractive
no
and she said laughing straight away what
do you think
um I think
men don't put that much effort to look
good do the majority of women
not attractive so no because of the fact
that a lot of men don't put a lot of
effort into looking good so example I
got roasted for this last time I said it
say it man right in terms of stats for
um cosmetic surgery women 95 percent
it's not because women want to go under
the needle and put their life at risk
it's because they want to desperately
look good for the men they want men have
this ego which means you know what a lot
of men a lot of women I mean rappers the
the 40 that are complaining rappers
because like not not because think about
it yeah uh the top Echelon or Elite men
out there who are not rappers who are
just like businessmen whatever their
their wives or girlfriends don't usually
look like big booty models they don't
so you're talking about women going
under tonight what do you mean okay
let's just clarify all BBL is not even
like noticeable nowadays A lot of girls
that you don't even know I've got a boob
job and you won't even you won't even be
able to tell because women are so
insecure about their looks now oh my God
the lips that they're doing nowadays
it's like every other girl you had
another girl oh my God the answer is
that when you say when you say who likes
who rates on a track notes I think that
most men uh will find more women
attractive than women find men
attractive that's true but men choose
looks as a more important part of their
dating profile than women do a man is
more likely to choose a woman almost
just based on how she looks some men
will whereas women won't as much as guys
say it women won't go after men just
because of what the men look like I
think that men have a oh no they'll bang
those guys they maybe women have it
women have a much larger pool of like
what is an okay look for a guy because
they don't care that much and I think
there is a lot of Truth to that that
like guys just don't look they don't put
as much effort you don't think you don't
think a lot of you don't think a lot of
women just sleep with guys they find
attractive just because they find
attracted there are some that too but
it's way less than men right a guy would
sleep with almost every single
semi-attractive and unattractive woman
he could some women might choose like
really try to guys sure but like in
general like no
no I agree like and I'm a woman so
you've never you've never said I never
ask you because you're a woman can I ask
you because you're a woman yeah no
you're happy in it so okay boom so what
you've never ever hooked up with a guy
just like you found him attractive you
know I'm just gonna hook up with him
you've never done that I'm not saying
I've never had a one-night stand but in
terms of there you go the men knife and
I'm sure most women have had one night
stands based on a guy being a Chad and
Tyrone
but when we're looking on average the
men I've slept with they're really not
my time I don't actually sleep with my
type because a lot of the time they
don't have respect for women and to me I
would rather a guy that is just it looks
okay I don't need you to be like gym
fanatic I don't need that I just need a
man that's gonna treat me well and a lot
of women are like that but men they need
a baddie they do that's not true
even Andrew Tate was talking about all
this stuff why are you referencing
Andrew he doesn't represent most guys
true true true true true but I seem to
hear it a lot where uh man they they say
she has a tiny way
yeah
see that girlfriend in real life
rappers oh I'll get your referencing
rappers your represent Andrew Tate okay
what are we listening to who else are
talking okay why are you why are you
taking your cues from rappers let me ask
you then let me ask you then how many
unattractive women on average have you
slept with oh loads because I've done a
lot out here so like most guys I'll be
real with you most guys that have slept
with a lot of women I've slept with a
lot of women they don't want to talk
about I'm just letting you into a little
secret even chadstone tyrones yes
they've stepped with a girl that is
probably below their standards but it's
a slow Tuesday
yes
um like what what's going on that's
absolutely true yeah but that's
basically what I said but that's because
of what I said earlier
said earlier was men's dating standards
and men's [__] standards are two
entirely different things for women they
tend to be more I'm gonna walk streets
on that thing real quick though and this
is I'm gonna speak totally anecdotally
here so no stats or data but like I've
seen a lot of guys that will post and
[__] they're like I can't find any girl
I don't know what's going on like I
think I look below average and it's like
a 6-2 guy that's got really broad
shoulders he looks really good his hair
is nice like bro you look fine and
there's a lot of these guys that are
like Ultra they just they don't know how
to talk to people
when you go through a lot of the dating
coaches like a lot of dating coaches
will find this and dude I see guys that
are [__] beautiful and it's like oh
my God and they're like yeah I know
girl's gonna talk to me because you know
I'm only five eleven and it's like
that's cap bro if you're 511 you're not
losing chicks because you're not tall
enough because you don't have the one
extra inch right so yeah I think that
there's a lot of toxic standards on both
sides sometimes yeah no I agree with
that 100
yeah
um
super chats yeah
it's a lot it's unlocked I mean today
was a bit more positive so I shouldn't
get was it
with the survivors I just think you
might look better next to the girl that
threatened me as I said I feel still
talking about oh yeah she outside I'm
honestly still in shock from that that
was crazy like she literally went from
zero to like one thousand like he was
just like that was that was worse than
the whale attack
okay Mr c73 cosmetic surgery does not
look good these are horrible examples
get some braces work out shave the legs
and down below um dialogue equals
progress
um destiny and that girl are so
emotional um Terrell Clark he's
emotional and Loud for no reason slow
down and calm down Albert retro women
get custody because of Caroline Norton
and The Tender Years doctor and not
because men don't want to be dads um
Terrell Clark in the U.S men are
sentenced to prison twice as likely as
women with 63 percent longer jail
sentences compared to women I'm JB
quinnin ninety percent of 501 c3s are
one run by women
um 3K Cod I can't say that name girl and
the white is annoying AF she should go
on fresh and fit they would destroy her
little pains she knows she's wrong but
she still goes on Megan H why is Esther
still on here rude much you can't even
answer a question because you don't like
the answer she knows her argument is
baseless JB quinnin by her logic 75
percent of black women wouldn't be
married that would suggest
um kid blue br27 I learned I I learn I
love I learn more I lean more red pill
but Destiny is wiping the floor with you
guys there needs to be a happy medium
but red red pill has gone delusional by
a young men mentalities fwu finally
waking up hey Pearl been subbed for a
month love your channel Sinister laugh
love you Pearl you'll be saved in the
flash drives of drives of History yay
um Albert retro you need to stop
going on red pill streams none of these
guys are actually red pilled they're
clowns
um Alex minor the more I see of Destiny
the more I'm convinced he can't handle
speaking with anyone with a different
opinion your feminine energy is coming
off strong
um LP burkstar on the topic of divorce
there are interviews where the female
said she was bored or thought she had
better options as a as a man who makes
more money see Dumbledore Destiny isn't
married he's pre-divorced to FW do fine
I'm sorry finally waking up let's be
real blue blue hair should never create
um JB Queen Quinlan would you rather
clean every day or die first in an
emergency more modern relationships are
miserable my God just stop talking about
all this non-nonsense and revert back to
traditional roles
LP bergster I know plenty of
relationships that guys work 16 to 20
hours a day and his girlfriend only
works a safe eight hours a day how can
you expect somebody who works double the
hours to come home and start doing
housework Marcus the average male jobs
are trades a blue-collar worker could
easily be out earned by a woman but be
more physically exhausted than she is
you always assume earned is just lazy
truck King the girl in The Purple wants
to smash the alpha take notes
um Steve slay Ron sign language Mr
Samuels was right again um FW finally
waking up masculinity is censored online
not feminism Sinister laugh the fact
that women can't be can be successful
has nothing to do with feminism it has
to do with availability times change
um real friends real from Sapient hi
Ally Richie's you have every right to be
picky the gym sucks
muscles be sore and I'm sure you've cut
weight before too chicken and broccoli
is how you earned it King Xavier thank
you kindly Destiny the average man isn't
that picky in terms of marriage plenty
of women with 20 plus body counts got
married by them wealthy them wealthy men
are picky
um
okay guys I'm just gonna try to do the
10 20 and up Sinister lap wow you said
every child my mom donated five dollars
[Laughter]
this is gonna be too long Alma Destiny
does not speak for the average common
man he's speaking for maybe five to
percent five to seven percent of weird
boom to be our betas
um
Terrell Clark you misread the report so
the men could turn down due to lack of
confidence and that's why they were
celibate for a year or forever John 9
the man did nothing with
the man did nothing what the heck and
Auntie could at least explain why she
didn't like them calling her bro common
guys more likes to Pearl for what she
has to endure here Doug MPA women make
85 cents per every dollar a man makes in
Jamaica women make 80 cents per every
dollar a man makes in Barbados women
make 54 cents to every dollar a man
makes in the Dominican Republic the
whale needs to stop capping
um JB Quinn and statistically tall women
are equal to short men in the dating
market for
for tall for a woman is over five four
shorter women are more married
Panda truck did Pearl just Frank Castle
of 304. I don't know if it was a Frank
Castle it was like a self
Castle no it's a friend he was a friend
I have a question what is three or four
like I've been seeing it it's like it's
a home it's a hoe that's what I mean
these red pills are so weird they come
up with their own words it's like it's
like on a calculator if you turn it
upside down it's like oh I don't
actually so rip it was on there it's
basically playing with calculators in
math problem
I mean that's probably how it started um
see Dumbledore welcome to the state of
Modern Woman wasn't she staying 15
minutes ago how great and high value and
mature she was all evidence to the
contrary
um she went full Karen on this podcast
uh Destiny looks like a Smurfette with
like Destiny looks like a Smurfette with
crossbred with Frodo Baggins
um Tyrell Clark imagine being This
Woman's husband poor guy every
um the fallacious truth every man in my
situation I have talked to when they
didn't try for their child their lawyer
told them not to bother my brother told
me not to bother I fired him and got
another you were wrong
um the fallacious troop truth blue hair
man child as a single father I had to
strategize over two years to get my son
even after I filed a protection from
abuse order over forty thousand dollars
in court fees I now have my son
um crypto keeper I want a tall glass of
pearly things
um how do I get in the DMS
um oh my God that's your five five King
Destiny you're hilarious NSX Destiny
quoted lead attorney Pearl is right I
watch the entire stream plus other oh I
read this one already okay
um wow you did it
no I skipped a lot wow there I mean
there's that was gonna be forever um
okay I was gonna close out the show so
thank you guys all for coming
um any hey we made it look who's left
I don't think I've done enough fresh
fish though
so I wanna I wanna literally can't
believe that happened I want to point
out why you said TV you said Africa is
the best why not but Nigeria is the best
I'm Nigerian oh I mean I think she was
ready why would you say you want to go
to South Africa so bad because the top
producers South African why
hey give me some give me some white
power
but I just said that because I just felt
like some type of way of the way she she
addressed the whole um Caribbean you're
African and I'm gonna speak like I just
kind of it just rubbed me the wrong way
like it's not that deep like you know
what I'm saying I don't really
understand why she left Caribbeans
anywhere a lot to Africans though they
think now they're better than Africans
because I'm very much but there's a lot
of tension in that respect but I just
feel like like obviously I like bro at
the end of the day if you're really
gonna take that as like oh yeah I'm
gonna leave I mean that's up to you in
it and I think and and anyone watching
anyone that's ever watched a video with
me when I do the podcast with the girls
I call everyone bro everybody bro it's
not now the um especially being
disrespectful to anyone right I don't
think you I think I don't think you
meant it like that and I I don't know
we're just gonna move on I don't know
yeah but I think you should okay try and
listen to people though
okay so we're going to close out the
show so any final thoughts please 30
seconds or less
um and you can plug in your social media
where they can find you whatever so
starting here and then go around oh
final thoughts no can we go start on
this side I need to talk about it fine
uh Michael do you want to start
all right we got to me
nah listen King rich is on YouTube go
check out my channel uh we got podcasts
over there over there we've got uh shows
podcasts reaction videos everything
um yeah go check out the channel and
what's my final thoughts uh
yeah maybe I should stop calling people
bro but you know it's just the way I
speak it's not on me trying to
especially be disrespectful if you take
it disrespectfully you know you know
sorry in it like but that's just how I
speak in it don't take it as a deep
thing I don't think I deserve to get
sliced up for it but you know that's
what some people think but it's cool in
it good luck on the streets tonight yeah
yeah thank you
okay Destiny yeah uh Big Ups to Pearl
for hosting this great show uh you can
find me at youtube.com Destiny that's
all I go
um Pearl stop saying Esther you need to
listen it actually is quite decision
everything's disrespectful these days
but it is
disrespectful to not to over talk a
homestein oh oh purple I'm talking I'm
talking you need to listen because you
talk I'm talking it's my time it's my
time to talk how does that feel you talk
the hold Esther how does that feel okay
but it's my turn it's my turn okay
I'll give you no time I'm gonna give you
no time all right your turn go go your
turn your turn okay then all right
maybe we didn't all survive yeah
then get out okay okay then then get out
then get out after Esther then get out
come here then ask her ask her I don't
care Esther Esther Esther I'm not gonna
get it
looking
because because after because you were
being rude Esther go get then get out
get the Esther Esther Esther get Esther
Esther get out Esther Esther get out get
out of my get out of my apartment get
out no get out no get out get out I'm
not gonna do that
anyways faster no your mic is muted get
the [__] out of my apartment get out get
out you're gonna be disrespectful the
whole goddamn show get out yeah I'll
call security I'll literally call
security that's very rude no can you
call security no no because you are
being rude because you are over talking
me call security get her out
foreign
anyway so you guys can follow me at
Sophie joyex on Instagram I'm going to
be doing a lot more podcasts and
political uh Media stuff and yeah I hope
to I this is a lot of fun and yeah can't
wait to do more
oh my God
yeah
no I wonder that's fine I wanna no
because it's not fair and I'm so sorry
you don't invite me into your house and
then try to disrespect me by kicking me
out I am sorry I'm going to have my
voice no if we're going to be here
security we're all gonna talk because
we're not gonna do that that is very
disrespectful and that no that is that
you can you can put it no that's the
ultimate disrespect how dare you invite
me to your husband to try to kick me out
because I'm trying to tell you how I
felt about how you're treating me you're
just embarrassing yourself I'm not
embarrassing myself it's just so rude it
really is
it's a lot
but can I just say one last thing
already
I don't know why I did that to myself I
don't know why I even came I guess
bro I listen I we got to top producer we
got to pull big up to myself we got to
Destiny we got to the last remaining
guests so Sophie yeah and uh yeah man
um this is this is just a little message
to all you ones who want to go and do
podcast bro it's not easy ref it's not
easy yeah so just know what it is and
yeah go subscribe to my channel bro yeah
this happens a lot on my channel as well
yeah even more so go subscribe King
riches right now yeah go subscribe to my
Channel right now yeah if you like drama
like this go subscribe to my Channel
right now I feel like I won The Hunger
Games yeah well hold on we just said
that with four of us here okay
[Music]
I'm the last standing girl you know
what's crazy this is I swear to God this
has never happened in my year of shows
anyways
um okay guys it was a lot of fun I loved
it okay guys um thank you for watching
this this [__] show
these shoes Matt uh this is your first
show coming back yeah thank you for
watching this [__] show we love this
city thank you to Destiny for coming on
yes
enjoying this you know
um thank you guys for coming I
appreciate it I appreciate being able to
have these conversations guys make sure
you like the video I'd say respectfully
disagree but someone threatened me yeah
like I can't even say that um okay like
the video on your way out subscribe to
the channel also um guys follow my
Instagram just pearly things one
um
also sign up for the 10 tier if you want
to see me freestyle rap
um subscribe to the channel subscribe to
wife school and subscribe to just pearly
animations and make sure you go
subscribe to King Rich's Channel and
Destiny's Channel as well they're both
really great content creators like the
video on your way out and I'll talk to
you next time